a deranged man broke into the Pelosi's
home in the wee hours of the morning
mercilessly beating Nancy Pelosi's
husband Paul with a hammer fracturing
his skull
seriously injuring uh injuring him Paul
Pelosi is expected to recover but he had
to get brain surgery
it turns out now
first the individual was seeking Nancy
screaming where's Nancy and now we have
information on this individual's
potential motivations
well the media initially reported that
he had anti-covet conspiracies and was
posting things about the election it
turns out he's a self-identified member
of the green party has a pride flag in
front of his house and is a nudist I
don't know if you can necessarily put
him in any Camp because he's maybe just
crazy
but he's an identified member of the
self-identified member of the green
party so that's the left I mean I know
many of the higher profile leftists
would reject that and well you know it
is what it is but I'll I'll make sure we
get make that clear this guy is a crazy
person and I'm not I'm not convinced
that what he was doing is is uh reflects
on any coherent ideology if someone
showed up to the Pelosi's house with a
clear understanding of what was going on
in a political Mission I would say that
was political and that was you know
intended to be some kind of
assassination but this
this guy just seems crazy but we'll read
the story we'll get into that and also
we have way more developments on the
Elon Musk story at first it was reported
he was going to be unbanning people then
he said no no no one's getting unbanned
until a diverse moderation committee
comes together and convenes
then he said anybody who is you know
arbitrarily banned you know dubiously
banned will be reinstated so should get
interesting uh we'll go through that and
a bunch of other stories some people are
claiming Bots are being purged has left
us to lose followers but oddly
non-leftists and conservatives are
gaining tons of followers so we'll see
uh so uh yeah before we get started over
to timcast.com become a member support
our work click that join us Button as a
member you're keeping our journalists
employed you're helping this show
continue you'll get access to our
uncensored shows Monday through Thursday
at 8 pm as well as cast Castle Vlog
Tales from the inverted world don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
video right now you got to be the
notification you want to see in the
world there's so much to go through
joining us to talk about this and so
much more is Gavin wax thanks for having
me back Tim great to be here who are you
I'm a columnist with uh Town Hall
Newsmax American greatness I'm uh the
head of the New York young Republican
Club we're the oldest and largest Club
in the country and I'm a co-author of an
upcoming book uh the emerging populist
majority which should uh head to print
uh this December and uh writing with my
co-author and a good friend Iraq war
veteran uh Troy Olson right on right on
we also got the T-shirt vendor hey guys
my name is lucrative here of we are
change.org and uh today I decided to
wear my free as a bird shirt it of
course highlights Elon Musk musk smoking
a doobie inside of the Twitter logo if
you like this shirt you could get it on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do I am here thank you again so much for
having me I'd like that one a lot Luke
and I want it I'll mail you one I want
the one off your back yeah that'd be
great I'm a medium I'm a I'm a large I
was not around yesterday great news we
need to do Elon picked it up um I know
that now I see that he's starting a
council he wants to get advisors on to
figure out how to go about adjudicating
the system so Elon I am available if you
want some people have nominated me for
this Council and I can put you in touch
with a lot of great free software
Advocates uh we can get in touch with
Chris you already know Chris pavlovsky
but we'll we'll just start organizing a
lot of the heads of the social media
organizations and then see if we can
start federating and Beyond there's
there's things better than Federation
better than the fediverse the uh like
Noster and ostr particularly uh we'll
talk more about that as it becomes
topical
and I am surge.com uh liked Twitter so
far we've only been on it for like a day
it's been interesting it's also been a
lot of bad stuff too
and my friends we also have a new shirt
that's right we too sell shirts head
over to timcast.com click store and you
can get our new design stand your ground
in honor of Roberto Jr the noble rooster
so we have uh shirts with the image of
these it's Roberto Jr and he's going
like yeah and it says stand your ground
and we actually have flags and stickers
and posters this one is a poster 24x36
and it is a rooster raising his wings
and you know he's sending this around uh
the reason why we chose this is that
roosters will sacrifice their lives to
save their hands they will charge full
speed at a predator they know will kill
them if it if it grants the hens even a
few more moments to try and survive be
like the noble rooster stand tall and be
willing to sacrifice for the greater
good and the ones you care about I I had
the idea because we're you know I I was
reading about the Gadsden flag Don't
Tread on Me The Snake will bite you and
then I was like but what about the noble
rooster the noble rooster who would die
to save those he cares about I mean
that's powerful stuff right there and
then I honestly I just really wanted the
flag so I got a flag made and we're
gonna have it and I think it's really
cool go to timcast.com check the store
if you want to pick that one up let's
jump to the first story from the the San
Francisco Chronicle what we know about
David de Pape man accused of attacking
Paul Pelosi with a hammer first and
foremost the story is he broke into the
house I believe it was in the wee hours
of the morning screaming where's Nancy's
what they've reported and then
mercilessly beat Paul Pelosi with a
hammer I mean it's deranged and unhinged
but many people are trying to figure out
what the motivations of this man was of
course immediately people on the right
were saying sounds like crime it's San
Francisco why would we assume otherwise
I think that's logical many on the left
said clearly it's Republicans it's Maga
this is what they want for you well they
were wrong it turns out he listed
himself as a member of the green party
voting records show de Pape listed
himself as a member of the green party
years ago so this is not somebody who
just had it on his profile it's not it's
not the media just claiming it it's
actually in his records green party yo
green party is leftist now it's not like
antifa it's not like Democrats or
anything it's like its own you know sect
of leftists but that's what it is it was
an unhinged leftist conspiracy theorist
when I when I when I talk to people on
the left and I say that the left has
their share of conspiracy weirdos they
always tell me that's not true and then
you point out the weird hippie crystals
Natural Health anti-government anti-war
stuff and they say oh but that's not
really left wing and I'm just like shut
up dude bro the guy was a leftist I'm
not saying that's why he did it he was
an anti-government conspiracy theorist
this doesn't have to be about politics
it can be about a crazy guy but being
for Natural Health isn't a conspiracy
theory but but anyway
I'm saying there are conspiracy
theorists who have like a conspiracy
view of natural stuff it's kind of sad
how you know something tragic happened
something really bad happens someone
gets seriously hurt and the first thing
that happens is everyone jumps online
trying to blame it on some other
political opponent for their own
political purposes uh I think it's fair
to say this guy was crazy he was
unhinged he was absolutely a lunatic and
it's horrible it sucks what happened
here and of course it should be always
said that that this should never happen
and not out of place in San Francisco
which has a massive Mental Health Health
crisis you have people like this this
green party guy all over the street so I
mean it goes without saying that it's
probably just a matter of the crime the
homelessness I think he had a house he
lived with roommates or something yeah
dude had a pride there's a pride flag an
American flag pride flag in front of the
house apparently well he was it he was
living specifically he's a part of a
nudist organization in group two Public
Safety investigative reporter for NBC
bay area posted this image of this house
and there's a pride flag that is not a
right-wing dude now look I I agree with
you Luke and I also I think there's an
inherent problem with how we try to
fairly represent this if this was a uh
when when it was only known that he
posted election conspiracy theories they
were all like saying oh it's Maga it's
Trump supporters this proves that they
immediately latched on and went for the
political attack then we find out it's a
green party guy with a pride flag and we
go guys guys calm down we shouldn't make
this political right
that's that that's a huge problem I'm
not saying I know a solution I say we
should ban nudists and and put them into
camps clearly the nudists are surely
responsible for all of this and they
were working for this all along
especially with their secret society and
organization that they have set up in
San Francisco where they have been
clearly popping up out of nowhere
randomly all the time but I'm telling
you what if I'm just I'm just a match I
want you to bear with me and I want you
to imagine a perfect world for a moment
tomorrow Nancy Pelosi holds a press
conference and she says
what happened to my husband if he had a
Magnum 357 this wouldn't have happened I
am now in favor of the second amendment
that was my second thought the first
thought was well how injured was he
hopefully he's okay kind of thing and
then the brain surgery did he have a gun
he didn't fire on this this home
Intruder we should have gone in San
Francisco bro yeah so like if he had had
a gun and the guy broke in with a hammer
to crack his skull he probably would
have fired on the guy put him down and
then ended the invasion in in that that
again is a radical idea that makes no
sense at all clearly what we have to do
here is Ban hammers hammers are the
problem there's too many of them anyone
could just get them without any
background checks anyone could just
transfer a hammer to another person
clearly right now the government has to
intervene go to Home Depot immediately
shut down the Hammers no no no no no one
is actually saying band hammers we just
want Common Sense Hammer control okay
yes no military very great hammer
handles we don't want any scary hammer
heads no black hammers no black hammers
at all no it needs to happen no bump
stock no bump stock Hammer right can
somebody it's time to start making to
meet the memes whatever
it's time to start making the memes we
need to start making memes of bump stock
hammers pistol grip hammers pump action
hammers just have added friends
no no but Hammer foregrip but you
brought up a great Point Ian absolutely
people should be armed especially if
they're elderly especially if they're
living in a crime-ridden place like San
Francisco especially if they're popular
and everyone knows where they live this
is not the first time that the Pelosi's
have had their house targeted everyone
should have the right to defend
themselves and whether you're a woman or
someone who's elderly or someone who's
who's weak or fragile whatever it may be
what is the great equalizer is you
having the ability to be able to defend
yourself in a firearm does that more and
better than anything else out there I
also want to know what uh what
prescriptions he was on what pills
because this is really what it comes
down to It's A Mental Health crisis we
got a lot of people on these these heavy
antidepressants and it sends them off
the deep end and maybe he was just a
nice hippie peaceful Berkeley guy you
know just living out his best life in
the nude and then he snapped that's the
real story maybe he ate Taco Bell and
then he just went like
raw milk maybe the Taco Bell had a bunch
of ssris in it that someone just laced
in there accidentally when they were
working for the company and then you
know that brain chemistry just got all
out of whack and then now this is not a
natural health conspiracy but I do think
if you eat nothing but fast food your
brain is probably going to be messed up
in a certain way and what what I mean is
like simply put you're probably missing
some nutrients if you're only eating a
lot of this garbage like that Super Size
Me guy he said the reason he wanted to
eat McDonald's for for 30 days was
because if they serve breakfast lunch
and dinner they clearly want you to be
eating it their response like we don't
expect someone to eat to eat nothing but
McDonald's but it's like dude if you're
selling food people are gonna eat your
food that should be the regulatory
standard it's like if you only eat your
food for X period of time what are the
impacts it shouldn't just be the one-off
time you eat it it should be a uh a set
period of time over a month whatever it
is yeah otherwise you wouldn't should
have a prescription right if it's not if
you're not able to have it well I guess
what do they say with alcohol just use
it at your own that's how prescriptions
are regulated hasn't impact you over the
entire time of the prescription it
should be the same if you're for food a
month two months whatever it is so
here's what's funny he they say in the
San Francisco Chronicle that the dude
had a Blog with screeds about the ruling
class right-wing conspiracy theories and
racial slurs yo the the the the popular
stuff is left and right that's the thing
like he was Green Party
it was funny I saw someone post I can't
remember who posted it they said that
like the Venn diagram of uh a trump
supporter and a nudist Berkeley hippie
is not a circle and I'm like it probably
overlaps right to be to be completely
like for real a bunch of anti-war
leftists became Trump supporters well
eight million uh Obama voters nine voted
for Trump I mean there was a huge Bernie
contingent uh after the primary I mean
this is a real phenomenon and like you
said it's a populism that crosses
partisan lines and uh it really just
speaks to the anti-establishment nature
of a lot of these guys he's clearly
anti-establishment if you're going to
try to assign any kind of overarching
political ideology to him but beyond
that I mean where this guy falls on a
right left Spectrum who knows I mean
they mentioned he posted Q stuff too and
that's why I'm like the dude's clearly
just crazy yeah but if you want to play
games you know in the media well he was
a green party right there you go yeah I
think when you talk about ruling class
it's really an economic issue and that
can be left or right or up or down I
suppose pose well it's really not yeah
it's not that linear Spectrum it's that
square you know the Libertarians always
like to use with the authoritarian
non-authoritarian economic uh statism
you know lazy fair so if you put it on
that it makes a little more sense but he
was a hemp jewelry maker like I just no
wonder he went off he's probably blown
his mind out on psychoactives is Mike
where's Nancy so Daily Mail he had a hit
list of other politicians yeah well I'm
glad he's Behind Bars is that what's
either what's this he's facing attempted
murder charges yeah right now was he
going to be let off he's Canadian it's
Canadian oh there you go also really
apparently anti-semitic as well
I think he's just crazy yeah and and
that's the first thing you know it's
it's funny that what's going to happen
now based on the cue stuff and the
election stuff is the left is going to
say he's a right winger right and then
when you point out he's a green party
they're going to be like no that doesn't
matter because he did this you know what
I mean what annoys me about this is that
you go to the city and you have attacks
like this on the subway weekly monthly
constantly Asian Americans Jewish
Americans whoever it is they get
attacked by lunatics like this and those
guys are out you know within a week from
bail reform or whatever and then
obviously it finally hits home to the
elites and I'm not trying to downplay it
it's obviously horrible what happened to
her husband but it just goes to show
that you know it's only becoming an
issue and there's only going to be some
serious there was a guy in New York City
that was caught on a viral video putting
an ax in front of a woman's face after
smashing up a McDonald's threatening to
to essentially and they interview her
with it he got out the next day and he
was on New York one he was doing
interviews he was on the media circuit
and he was like oh listen I just had a
it was hot I had a rough day and it was
like yeah this guy have been this guy
and then and then a couple days later he
got arrested again from stealing a bike
and running away after doing graffiti
and and again this guy of course is
going to have a very stiff sentence this
guy is of course going to be kept in
jail other people who commit other
crimes unregular Joe smells they just
get let go every single day because of
the George Soros appointed District
Attorneys all throughout the United
States that have been causing Havoc
everywhere and when I was talking about
banning Hammers and blunt objects we got
to understand many years according to
the FBI statistics more people have died
from hammers uh than than rifles I'm
pretty sure it's illegal to walk around
Chicago with a baseball bat well it
depends if you're coming from like a
baseball field like it depends on how
you're brandishing it right no uh my
understanding at least this is what the
cops told us they were like if we see
you with a with a baseball bat we can
arrest you for a possession of a weapon
but typically if you have a baseball bat
and a baseball together they could but
you probably won't get in trouble but
that's how that's how broken things are
so in in Illinois I'm pretty sure like
the only way weapon or in Chicago the
only weapon you can have it used to be
this way pre the uh what was the
decision in DC was it uh Heller was it
Heller I don't know you don't want to
look it up the handgun decision in 2008
it was a hell it was how to learn versus
you could only have a two foot long
rubber switch for a whacking somebody
wow yeah and and all the criminals had
guns right so you know we know how that
worked out it's just asymmetrical
Warfare you know law-abiding citizens
you know you're off on your own with
that rubber thing you just mentioned and
good luck bringing it to a gunfight dude
I don't know if you guys saw this video
out of New York where there's some
there's there's a guy there's a guy in
the hood on the subway and then another
guy is walking money with business first
guy just runs full speed and then boom
body slams him right onto the tracks and
then runs for it what happened to that
guy that got knocked on the tracks I
don't know about that guy I know that
several people have been killed yeah
what would you do I mean happened in
front of you jump down on the tracks
grab the guy and get him up onto the
platform you try I guess like you don't
want to land you're gonna make sure he's
not touching the third right now and you
can't touch him you have locked in well
there's always delays or blown back
every time there's a delay like that I
mean you know what happened you may not
be at that stop you may be a while away
but it's a commute either either someone
did it themselves it's a suicide or one
of these instances when I lived in New
York I used to think like okay I don't
need to work out all the time I wasn't
obsessed with being strong but I was
like I need to be strong enough so that
if someone falls on the track I can jump
down and get them up out of the track I
consciously think about where my head
would land if I was just pushed if it
would make it to the track and I just
try to give myself an extra foot or two
in case someone comes from behind but
depending on the force it doesn't really
matter they can get you on that onto the
tracks if they really push and then I'm
sure MTA will say don't go down there
it's too dangerous don't put yourself at
risk if someone falls on the track but I
I that wasn't through my head I'm like
God I hope that guy's okay is it uh Luke
was it Japan or Singapore where they
have glass blocking it's in Japan there
was in high school when they installed
those and it's like basically just doors
that are exactly like the train doors
they open and then they allow you to go
through the door and then the airports
yeah separate glass line just I think
Japan does that too Japan does that as
well not for crime and then suicide if
you kill yourself in Japan there's
particular uh lines and particular
access roads where there's bigger fines
for the family members of the individual
that killed themselves than other
roadways that aren't as popular so your
family gets fined like in Japan if you
kill yourself that is interesting they
have seppuku right which is like a
historical a traditional thing of like
an honor suicide or whatever and so it's
interesting that that there is an
element of some kind of high suicide in
Japan I wonder if that's just like a
cultural thing persisted so people are
more willing to do it I don't know
culture long working hours you know it's
a I feel it's a litany no families no
babies they sell more adult diapers than
baby diapers that's coming to a country
near you the population coming it's here
it's it's already here yeah we went we
went to a theme park
and uh this was the Halloween party the
theme park it was dead there was no one
there well this is why Disney is
Shifting to like Nostalgia porn for like
30 40 year olds because they don't have
that child Family Market anymore no I
predicted this
um
recently that the phenomenon of Abe
Simpson saying you know when I when I
was young I was with it then they
changed what it was now what it is is
scary to me and it'll happen to you too
that's not going to happen to us yeah
and the reason is the millennial
generation is probably going to be the
biggest generation drop-off that's it so
we're the top of the hill and uh gen z
may be a little bit bigger so maybe it's
gen Z but afterwards it's going to get
lower and smaller in the populations
already Contracting that's a fact
outside of any pandemics War World War
III or otherwise the future Generations
are smaller and smaller so what's going
to happen is Disney's shifting Nostalgia
marketing for one simple reason they're
like we got 30 million potential
Millennials to sell to or 10 million
kids some of the older Millennials
there's more of them there's more money
if 10 million little kids getting
brought a dollar what are we gonna get
right if the Millennials come they'll
bring their kids we'll get even more
money Target The Nostalgia so that means
they're going to keep trying to Pander
to the millennial probably like a range
of millennial to Gen X with mostly
Millennial in the middle that's where
they're going to be targeting I don't
think people realize when you hit these
TFR total fertility rates like 1.2 1.3 I
mean the drop-off is significant and
Japan is just going to be suffering like
you know population decline in the
millions they already are same with
China China
all of Eastern Europe Western Europe
well so so uh we went to this haunted
house then there was booze and there was
food and there was rides and it was a
little older crowd it was packed we go
to the theme park mostly for kids I mean
like there was a zip line there that I I
sat on and then I was hitting the ground
because they're like I'm just I'm a man
you know but I was well under the weight
limit well under and uh it's like it was
like a family thing and so we went there
and it was mostly kids but there was
like 30 in the whole place so where I
was just I was like yo where is
everybody
people don't have kids where are the
kids I don't know it was did it cost
money to get in yeah maybe they were
broke well you like you get a charge
card to do anything in the park and then
spend money like 30 bucks to get in or
something no no no like you get a card
and if you want to do anything you can
tap the card too so it's like you want
to play mini golf you tap it if you want
to go on a ride so it's free to get in
and then it's like pay per ride but you
can't do anything unless you get a card
it's just the signs of a Dying society
and then you have the other side of it
is that the the Millennials these young
adults they're just becoming
infantilized because they're not
progressing to the next stage of their
life you know with with a family or even
you know other things a business Etc
economic reasons intentionally
intentionally I mean look it's it's
great you have a smaller population to
control it's a lot easier than a
population growing that has to worry
about its posterity I mean you got these
leaders in in Europe like Merkel you
know she's not there anymore but none of
them had children so what do they care
what do they care about the future of
their their nation state whether it's
Germany or uh France whatever it is
Kamala doesn't have any children as well
does Justin Trudeau have any kids
I don't know I don't know probably
cousins in Cuba so I wonder if it's
these devices this is what Dr Phil was
saying oh yeah it's three kids
apparently um Dr Phil was like it's the
first generation of people raised on
these devices from since 2007. that's
this and then you've got the fentanyl
that the Chinese are putting into the
Mexican cartels that are being shipped
up to destroy our culture that way I
don't know if that's the intention but
that's what's happening it's like the
Opium one did you guys the food supply
you guys see the viral video where it's
like this Tick Tock young teenage girl
gen Z girl being like my mom won't give
up her CDs and she's filming and she's
like this is my family's CD collection
and my mom won't get rid of them and
then her mom is standing she goes I am
not getting rid of them I got rid of my
albums then they came back I want my CDs
and she goes mom I can play any one of
these songs faster on my phone and she
goes no it's because I don't remember
these bands you're like I like Oingo
Boingo I wouldn't even remember that
they were around unless I looked at the
CD but what's fascinating in that
interaction is the young kid
raised on the phone is like but I can
just play go and it's like you are too
young I suppose to understand no no I'm
sorry youth isn't the uh isn't the
reason for it you are lacking in context
and information there were people who
gave up their vinyl collections thinking
like vinyls going out the window vinyl
never died now all of a sudden they're
they're worth tremendous amounts of
money you go to these resale shops
antique shops and it's like the prices
are going up and up and up so so yeah
This Woman's like I'm not giving up
these CDs there's going to be a
Nostalgia Factor people are going to
want to pop those CDs in but she makes
another really good point yo when I put
on music on Pandora on Spotify I don't
even know half the bands that are
playing I don't grab my phone and then
type in music so that we don't know
phone numbers anymore right we don't
know phone numbers anymore but but the
main point is the commentary I saw on
this is you will own nothing and you
will be happy yeah this little kid is
like just rent the idea of music from
the machine mom what's the problem and
the mom's like I want my music that I
own tangible I like that you phrased it
that it was really the problem was the
ignorance of the kid uh it was the
ignorance of the human that was like
didn't realize the benefit of like if
they'd a vinyl because it's not gen Z
that's the problem it's the ignorance
and a lot of times kids are ignorant
just because they're kids and they don't
have the World experience yet some kids
actually aren't ignorant because they
have fantastic parents and some old
people are extremely ignorant you know
so it's not the youth that's the issue
but has any generation in human history
gone through so much technological
societal cultural change in such a short
period of time I mean these are things
that typically have happened over
centuries Millennia I mean if you look
at a a regular Joe schmoe from 1820 is
he that much different from 1720 1620
1520 I mean yeah there's things on the
margins but the change from say
post-world War II to today is on a scale
that we've never seen before and I feel
like it's almost evolutionary at this
point and I think it's leading to a lot
of the psychological issues we're seeing
a lot of the Mental Health crisis I mean
people can't cope with this change
they're just not it's not ingrained in
them yeah you would think that with
access to the world's information you'd
be able to solve every problem and then
every problem would be solved as a
result but just because we can does
obviously the test is shown doesn't mean
that we will correct uh yeah I think
this has been the most rapid advancement
in the human consciousness ever in the
history of and we and it's it's all
novel we don't know like where we make
fun of you know the Millennials the
Zoomers whatever they are but you know
there's really nothing to look back on
there's no historical point of reference
I hope what really happened is that like
aliens showed up at Roswell and then you
know it was an accident and they're like
ah crap meet with the government and
they're like here's right we're gonna
give you rapid Communications technology
to bring your your people up to speed
and they're like all right and now the
aliens are sitting back laughing as if
they gave chickens like Ultra weapons
and they're just watching us be really
done with it they're like they're gonna
wipe themselves out with this data
impropriety you know right they're doing
people understand the the the
algorithmic manipulation I don't know I
don't know if it was Elon Musk has said
this said this I think was he said the
the current thing may actually be chosen
by an algorithm so there are people who
are like on the Trends on Twitter being
like I I like mustard ice cream and it's
like a robot just decided to promote
that one day and now you're marching and
locked up with it the algorithm is the
the new Holy Spirit of our world exactly
it's just touching things in different
ways but uh what what you were saying
before about you know how they're you
know the people aren't processing you
know all these new Innovations Etc I
mean it's the same way of looking at it
as um uh you know it it's it's like you
you get a new toy and it's just like you
know a new a new Gadget a new car and
you're just obsessed with it you're just
diving into it head first and that just
becomes part of you that's your whole
existence now and I feel like we're
seeing that on a generational scale it's
just this Obsession this Tech Focus it's
but everything that we've designed
whether it's all this access to
knowledge we're not becoming smarter
we're not solving problems all this
access to social networks communication
we're becoming more and more
disconnected more atomized it's all
having this counter effect I think one
of the issues that we're facing clearly
is that there's just too many people and
we're not guiding reproductive
reproduction wisely so maybe the first
way to do is maybe like a a great reset
down to like 500 million people that's
the right marketing term then we'll
guide a population uh reproduction uh
what what is what do the Guidestones say
Luke I tried to do it no no the
guidestone said guide reproduction
wisely or something oh my God so the
that's that's the idea right the idea
they know better everyone knows better
except us well the algorithm is
producing reproduction digitally I like
that you phrase that that it's like the
Holy Spirit the algorithm is our current
is that what you said the whole yeah the
Holy Spirit yeah because imagine if
someone owned God and they were able to
control it and they knew what it was
doing but no one else knew what it was
doing and make everyone think and see
one particular thing when they want them
to see it you guys don't ban particular
ideas against that particular thing that
they want you to believe social
engineering that's Godlike power you
know be crazy you you know how they've
been trying to do this augmented reality
thing for a long time right like Google
Glass was like a rudimentary version
where you'd look up to the right there's
a little screen there right now they've
got the metapro questioning and like the
idea is they're like goggles and you'll
see the the real world but it'll augment
it
imagine in the future they tell
everybody
you know you can see through these
glasses you'll see everything like
normal and then you'll also see the
augmented reality stuff but the
augmented reality stuff is very easily
discernible from real life right the
graphics aren't as good until it's not
and then one day everybody sees the same
thing across the sky an explosion and
they don't realize it's actually a trick
in the augmented reality you see what
I'm saying or they don't want to take it
off because they take the glasses off
and everyone's fat ugly and miserable so
they put it back on everyone looks
beautiful what I'm saying is fake events
happen where everyone everyone thinks
with my AR goggles I choose what AR I
see so I'll load up my menu and I'll go
like this like this okay uh Facebook and
then you know Twitter and then tweet
send and then all of a sudden Kaboom
explosion in the sky and they think it's
reality but it's actually augmented
reality but everyone sees the same thing
reports seeing it and then everyone
assumes it really happened in fact yeah
yeah I've been noticing a trend on
Twitter the last couple weeks where at
the top you get that four you you big
thing and it says video about fill in
the blank was doctored experts say this
video recent video about White House
correspondent was doctored video was
doctored video was changed so like this
is like in the last two weeks I've
noticed this probably like four times or
five maybe four times that they're I
mean the age of deep fake is upon us
whether or not that's gonna be ar or
just actual video that we watch on TV we
don't even know or they'll accuse
they're being deep fakes so there was a
there was a story in the press that uh
Rhonda Santos met with Clarence Thomas
the day before the Dobbs decision came
down ending Roe v Wade the real story
was that a year and a day before the
media runs this story without fact
checking it and now the guy who wrote a
secondary it was a secondary source
reporting so emails get released by
non-profit Raw Story writes a story
independent copies Raw Story independent
then realized oops we get it wrong guy
says I'm so embarrassed to take it down
but think about this
the defamation of lying about somebody
in an election is the cost of doing
business for these people if if you can
win a governor governorship for four
years is it not worth the 50 million
defamation lawsuit and man these races
cost more than that so you can these
we're getting to the point where
fetterman's campaign's been just making
things up imagine how dark it's going to
get I was on when I was on when I was on
Rogan's show it was like a year ago he
asked me how I felt about deep fakes and
I said I'm not I don't think it's going
to get that crazy I think it won't be no
no and now I'm like I was way wrong
they're going to make a deep fake and
it's going to be a grainy video of
Rhonda's supporters to make it look like
it's a cell phone so it's easily faked
and he's gonna say something not
ridiculous just kind of bad right the
the the real effective stuff is not
going to be Rhonda Sanders coming out
and screaming the n-word it's going to
be himself it's going to be him saying
something like look when it comes to
covid there's only so much you can do so
yeah are people gonna die a lot of
people are gonna die I can't be bothered
with it all the time something like that
where it's like believable and there's
there's going to be a wild west period
as this Tech rapidly develops that
there's no legal precedent for the
defamation like you're saying so how are
they going to treat these deep fakes
what are the repercussions going to be
and it's going to be an insane period of
time before the law catches up if the
law and the regulatory system ever
catches up it may not these things are
going to appear in court yeah and then a
video not only that
a real video will appear in court and so
I'm like I filmed this guy punching a
dog and I'll say deep fake you won't
believe it and then and then you're dude
it's this is a grand deep Victory call a
lawyer you you get your lawyer your
lawyer finds an expert and they said
your lawyer calls 10 experts here's the
video is it a defect nope that's real
okay expert number two is it deep fake
no it's real number three no four five
finally expert number ten
looks like a deep fake to me excellent
you're hired would you like to appear at
this trial then he shows up and says to
the jury I am a video expert I've been
working for 20 years I watched the video
it does not seem genuine now this dude
who actually committed a crime could
maybe even get off to us just because
the technology exists so when we have
experts in court are we should we have
to say how many experts were interviewed
and then how many experts were chosen no
of the 12 experts this the one that we
chose says this the other nine or eleven
said this that's not how it works I
think we need more transparency in our
legal system especially with software
code and apparently with experts end
quote if we're going to be putting
people on the stage what if what if okay
let's how about another scenario
a crazy uh extremist makes a deep fake
of you punching a dog you get arrested
you go to an expert and he goes you're
in a Crossland
from from Tim kiss uh I don't want to be
involved I I it's real it's real and
they go through nine experts who all say
the same thing like dude I don't I don't
want to be targeted it's a real video
and then finally they get one guy who
goes I don't care what show you're on
Ian I watched the video I did the
analysis it's fake and then you go to
trial and they say but let's pull up the
nine other experts and they all go oh
it's a real video please please don't
burn my house down it's a real video
what what's sad about all this is we
could talk about you know the
theoretical implications of these deep
fake technology but you know you have
this media class that will publish
defamatory hit pieces without even using
deep fakes they'll just claim you said
something you believe something you are
something white supremacist racist Nazi
whatever and they don't need a deep fake
they'll just print it put in the
headline and that's what you are you're
branded and there's no recourse which
goes back to you know the state of our
defamation laws and it's only going to
get worse with the Deep fake it's only
going to get worse but it's pretty bad
right now and we have no solution
cultural reinforcement man I I think
about like I I feel like the only
solution is to get people to come
together to believe in the things I
believe in in order to revive this crazy
there's no National consensus ever
coming back anytime soon and you know I
I don't know how do you deal without
manipulating people let's jump to this
next door let's get to Elon Musk here so
from timcast.com Twitter accounts will
not be reinstated until new content
moderation Council convenes says Elon
Musk he says Twitter will be forming a
Content moderation council with widely
diverse viewpoints no major content
decisions or account reinstatements will
happen before that Council convenes
let me just break this down for all you
guys
first it is a victory a tremendous
victory that Elon Musk has purchased
Twitter I'm glad to see that something
good is happening but Elon
like us is making a mistake
earlier on in the show in a previous
segment Jose just tuning in
for those Justinian we mentioned that
the person who attacked Paul Pelosi at
the Pelosi house was a leftist we also
wanted to mention that he does have a
bunch of weird conspiracies it's a
nudist and it's probably just a crazy
person meanwhile leftists are trying to
claim he's a Maga guy because he denied
the election and posted Q stuff at any
moment in every moment the left will
outright just be like it's Maga Marjorie
Taylor green said we won't forget the
companies that stopped donating because
of 2020 and a prominent Twitter leftist
said this is a direct threat and it's
why Pelosi got attacked blah blah blah
they go to the extreme end Elon Musk is
telling us right now he's going to
invite them
to sit down and discuss how to handle
censorship you see before Elon bought
Twitter he said the appropriate solution
should be where there's a compromise and
everyone's a little unhappy but he
doesn't realize the conservatives the
independence and Libertarians
post-liberals have already compromised
saying outright we accept the left will
say naughty words we just want to be
able to express our opinions the left
then says we want you banned and we can
do whatever we want there's no
compromise there because you've got one
side that already compromised and the
left saying to everything or nothing if
Elon Musk is going to form a a a
moderation Council and invite the woke
left Indigo but my feelings are hurt
when he said I was ugly then he's gonna
go all right well let's give the left a
little bit of what they want the only
problem that is literally what
vajayagare and Jack Dorsey did Jack
Dorsey and Vijaya were basically running
Twitter like okay conservatives don't
care that left us are on the platform
they won't leave so we don't have to do
anything for them they're content but
the left will leave unless we ban some
conservatives here's the compromise we
don't ban all of the conservatives only
a few to make the left think we're doing
something and then the right won't leave
because we're not Banning ever everybody
that's the problem this will not work
it's a bad move and Elon needs to go in
now independently of his own volition
and release the political prisoners and
he needs to accept he is responsible for
this and there's no diverse Viewpoint
that's going to solve the problem amen
and I hope this is just fluff to cover
you know his tracks from a PR
perspective for any next moves but he
has to come out guns blazing you know
open up the prison cells release
everybody and just overwhelm the left
with all the reforms and changes he's
gonna make because if he starts doing a
piecemeal they're gonna just attack it
piecemeal and they're going to divide
and conquer and it's going to be this
messy drawn out situation with this
ridiculous fluffy sounding Council which
honestly sounds no different than things
they've done in the past it's exactly
what they already were doing yeah if
you're going to build a council don't
build a council of people to decide who
gets banned and who gets unbanned get a
council of people to decide how to build
a system so that the Bannings and
unbannings can happen judiciously right
nothing good comes out of committee tell
us about minds the mind's jury system is
legitimate I think this is the way to go
is so what happens is if you're on mines
and your stuff gets flagged uh someone
in the administrative team will be like
okay that they got flagged they get
banned and then if you don't agree you
appeal it it goes to people that have
opted in on mines to the jury system
like up to 12 or more random people get
the content it says does this violate
the terms of service then they have an
opportunity to swipe right or swipe left
if they're on their phone or whatever
say yes or no if it violates it or if it
doesn't so if enough people say yeah it
violates it you're still banned you can
appeal it maybe twice you can three
times uh if you say no it doesn't
violate it you get a majority of people
then it's unbanned and then if it gets
flagged again goes back through the
process now if someone if a jury member
is saying it doesn't violate the terms
but it does and they keep repeatedly
doing that on things that keep coming up
and they keep getting it wrong they
eventually lose their ability to be on
the journey that shouldn't happen I
disagree because I think people will
abuse it what they'll do is they'll vote
how they want it I want it to be on the
site but that's not what I'm asking I'm
asking if it violates the terms jury
nullification is exactly I think this
shouldn't be illegal and I won't convict
someone well notification needs to exist
and hold on the reason why I think
that's a bad move a bad element of it is
that let's say the platform becomes
dominated by really awful people who
want to see free speech ban Wikipedia
and there's a hand exactly and a handful
of people are saying this didn't break
the rules why are you saying it did and
then all of a sudden Minds comes down
and says look the majority has repeat
repeatedly said you're wrong so we're
removing you well then what would happen
the scent must be allowed I think what
would happen is an admin at mines would
review if if like a bunch of people are
saying it's not violating it's not but
it is and then you're like okay who are
all these accounts that keep saying it's
not violating why do they keep saying
it's not what it is
violent when it doesn't it sounds good
on paper but this is how Wikipedia
devolved and you have this this
organized ideologically driven minority
maybe on that platform that decides the
edits that approves the edits that
controls the entire editing hierarchy it
will be taken over Fabian style but the
argument is because it's a random
selection of jurors every time but
there's no there's no um cabal right but
you can't punish a juror for giving
their honest thoughts you can downrank
their no their ability if they're not
accurate No this needs to be not
absolutely not I think so it's a private
company make it a dictator imagine
imagine if we said in public in a
legitimate criminal trial you're like
this guy is not guilty and like well
everyone else said he was you must be
wrong we're not going to let you be on a
jury trial anymore that is insane well
this is you have a civic duty right if
it's illegal it's off it's off the site
I mean if that's an illegal thing and
someone's saying it's legal then I don't
think they should be a juror
I I I understand that but that means you
have to review every single person
whether they said it was good or bad or
you can algor you can algorithmically
calculate people that are inaccurate and
then just over time downrank it's the
Holy Spirit again but the algorithm
would be public it would be like a free
software algorithm that you can go on
GitHub and look at so so the facts
matter here when it comes to this
particular case and there's a lot of
other things happening uh behind the
scenes there's a lot of things happening
with a coordinated media push right now
to try to get advertisers off of Twitter
but uh Elon Musk just 20 minutes ago
tweeted that there have been no changes
to the Twitter content moderation
policies he also tweeted today that
quote comedy is now legal on Twitter
Michaela Peterson responded to him and
asked hey can can you get my father back
on the platform and he said specifically
quote anyone suspended for minor and
dubious reasons will be freed from
Twitter jail that's a direct comment
from Elon Musk on his official Twitter
account now let's Factor this in a lot
of people have been banned on Twitter a
crap ton of them would you you want to
be the one solely responsible looking at
that list saying okay okay okay no this
guy did something bad here going through
all the history here I wouldn't want
that recipe I wouldn't want that job
this is why he's announcing some kind of
counsel how will he handle it it's going
to be interesting I just hope he's not
being swayed by The Washington Post that
by the way uh again I talked about this
yesterday Bill Gates literally is
putting money into organizations to
launch attacks on Twitter right now he
has been doing this and and has been
planning this for months The Washington
Post came out today and is telling
people how to turn off their
advertisements on their settings on
Twitter so they could sabotage Twitter
and of course the money that they get
from advertisers GM just announced that
their temporary suspending ads on
Twitter what will happen moving forwards
well I'm still optimistic his tweets are
saying he's going to to to make sure
that he's going to undelete the censored
people on on social media including
people like Jordan Peterson I'm hopeful
I think he's going to do it but I think
it's going to take time he needs to hold
the line he needs to realize it's going
to be tough in the beginning obviously
with the advertisers the pressure
campaigns Etc but they have nowhere else
to go from an advertising perspective
they're going to come back this was
never going to be a financially
lucrative deal at least not for a long
for the long run Twitter was never
making money so the advertising is just
sort of putting off some of the
financial losses that the company's
suffering but at the end of the day he
needs to come out he needs to be bold he
needs to unban these people immediately
and if he Dilly dallies if he Dithers
they're going to smell blood they're
going to jump on it and they're going to
come after him his reputation's on the
line because he you know this was a
massive ordeal that he undertook and you
know I think I agree with everyone here
it's going to be better no matter what
on the margins but if he backs off and
he doesn't fulfill it I mean he's going
to look like a total fool I mean he's a
TOEFL he owns the company it's private
he has full dictatorial Powers
effectively to set these standards he
could you know devolve some power to
some stupid counsel but the end of the
day he should come out set the standards
set the the maximum from everything to
follow and if they follow it good and if
they don't follow it well he has other
problems or at least I hope you're wrong
but but I I kind of agree with you that
he should at least do the basic ones
Jordan Peterson project Veritas that's
going to be again I mean just those
Basics alone are clear obvious you don't
need a committee and a commission to to
figure out that that was absolutely
wrong for those people to be censored
right and the people down the hierarchy
you know these minor accounts these
no-name people that were banned for a
variety of reasons that's going to be
more complex so it's probably going to
take a lot of time and Logistics fine we
all understand that but it takes all
five minutes like you said to look at
Jordan Peterson and say okay bring him
back on Elon crossed the Rubicon
he he declared war on the cathedral
they've run and in panic and he's taken
Rome it is now his Empire
he needs to just accept what he's done
and make the changes he wants to make I
don't understand why he would not
immediately reinstate The Babylon be
everyone knows he did this because of
the Babylon be the Babylon bee did
literally nothing wrong he said comedy
is allowed once again the first thing he
could have done and if I was Elon I'd
take my phone I'd press record I'd walk
in the front doors of Twitter I'd look
at the camera and go hey guys hey who
works here unban The Babylon B I'm
filming get it done now I'm counting I'm
glad you made the Cesarean reference
because Caesar came into Rome and was
forgiving and you know gave everyone a
second chance and then Brutus you know
stabbed him in the back and the rest of
the Senate so he cannot go into Rome and
take this Caesarean approach that he's
going you know love his enemies and give
everyone a second chance all the
optimates and the and the Senators and
the rest of the Twitter Twitter audio
Elite he needs to come in with an Iron
Fist and crack some skulls and just make
it clear that this is the new law of the
land and we're not backing down and they
will they will back off but at the same
time if he does something he's going to
have thousands of people come to him
what about me what about me can you do
me can you do me can you do me and
that's a lot of pressure from a lot of
powerful people that were censored
incorrectly he's only one guy he needs
15 minutes in between you know what I
mean I think you come into Rome you
immediately lay out your new
Constitution and then give the power to
the people to govern themselves we don't
even we don't even agree protocol with
jury system uh
um constitutional values unban anyone
that didn't violate U.S Lawns wherever
the headquarters San Francisco is the
headquarters so it doesn't violate
California state law then unbanned right
from the beginning then you decide if
you need to ban them for terms of
services so also all the terms of
service are going to change now right
that's well yeah the misgendering
policies got to go not every word but
it's up to Eli he can be as creative as
he wants with in terms it's this simple
check out the mind's terms make it a
protocol give yourself access to the
real estate
make the real estate sellable the
advertising real estate as an as a
commodity or asset on a public protocol
and then you you effectively give
yourself you make it worth substantially
more money you remove moderation
requirements from you and say if someone
look here's the way I describe it if
Coca-Cola buys a billboard in Times
Square and then I go stand in front of
it holding up a sign with a picture of
something really awful
is Coca-Cola going to call up their ads
that buyer and be like hey are their ad
seller and be like oh well why is there
a man standing in front of my sign
saying naughty words they're gonna be
like because he's standing on a public
Street next question what's white
wasting my time we should not be looking
at Twitter in this way if if you want to
advertise where the conversation is
happening you recognize people say
things you don't like period right they
make it a protocol they make it
interoperable with other platforms they
remove their ability to moderate
anything and say law enforcement can
handle it and also with the advertising
I mean this was a dying platform this is
mostly used by journalists certain
niches of society it's not this Mass
public platform like an Instagram or
even a snap or even a a tick tock it is
a platform for you know different
degrees of Elites essentially talking to
other Elites and then a few people
liking it the advertisers will come when
he creates when he turns it back into a
platform that people want to be on
people want to engage in have engaging
people and it's not this controlled
manipulated bot infested platform which
it is now which is and he bought it
extremely overvalued so he turns it back
to what it should be the advertisers
will return and any political
disagreements they have in the interim
will be you know things of the past I
actually posted an old video of Elon
Musk talking about Twitter making fun of
I I posted this on my shorts on my
YouTube channel which people get to
watch I definitely recommend you watch
that because Elon Musk talked about his
plans for Twitter he talked about how
it's absolutely crazy that it took
Twitter one year to work on something
like an edit button right he then went
on it was like you know we should make
this like WeChat and then and WeChat is
something that's not really popular here
in the United States but in places like
China everyone depends on WeChat for
virtually almost every aspect of their
life and existence you do everything on
WeChat and this is the type of vision
that he has that he might transform and
change Twitter to 2X and again Twitter
made some horrible absolutely idiotic
decisions when it came to their business
they run owned Periscope they ruined
Vine they had the tick tock before Tick
Tock even existed Tick Tock right now is
dominating all the social media
platforms with so many users with so
much engagement with so much uh just
short-term uh gratification for a lot of
individuals whether it's good or bad
that's debatable but but YouTube and and
but excuse me Twitter had that live
streaming ability had that Tick Tock
ability and they just threw it in the
trash they deprecated everything it's
been a history of deprecating features
refusing to release features it's it's
interesting than the last year with
Twitter blue with the edit button with a
whole Litany of other features it's all
come out of you know the Woodworks
because up until then it was just a
series that they had fleets for a while
I remember yeah I got rid of fleets that
was a little it was they literally had
Vine
to be the number one Marketplace video
service right now they had they could
have been it and arguably if you make a
comparison to Facebook if Facebook had
not acquired Instagram Facebook would be
done by now I mean Facebook its platform
is is dying it's Instagram that keeps it
afloat had Twitter successfully kept AI
they would be in a totally different
position today absolutely I want to pull
up this story from timcast.com
advertisers threatened boycott if Trump
reinstated to Twitter clients from Ad
Agency that spend 60 billion dollars per
year in media spending will pause all ad
purchases if Trump's account returns why
why are advertisers saying we don't want
Trump on the platform what do these
things have to do with each other other
than these are ESG companies it's
politically motivated Elon Musk needs to
recognize this but it seems like he's
he's bowing to it well these are what do
you call impact investors and they're
willing to throw money at political
causes they want to see someone other
than Donald Trump be elected the nice
thing about owning this company and
making it private is that he doesn't
when you have a public company yeah you
have not only do you have shareholders
then you even a public private company
that you have that you co-own with
someone else like in the case of Mines
Bill and John ran it together they each
owned half it was hard to get stuff done
because if Bill wanted to do something
it had to go through John and if John
didn't want to do it it didn't happen so
I imagine at Twitter there's like six
guys all with veto power impossible like
you said it took a year to get an edit
button right through now you got one
owner he says yes it gets done right so
it's the power of the dictator there's
also a global corporate collusion with
Bankers happening under the name of the
ESG and I think this has a lot to do
with it because if they can have
companies literally jumping whenever the
bankers want them to jump uh singing
whenever the bankers want them to sing
doing whatever the bankers want them to
do under this social credit score this
corporate social credit score this is
another element of it that we have to
understand here this is a coordinated
effort by a lot of very powerful people
Bill Gates being one of them putting all
of his money into institutions saying
hey hurt Twitter now Twitter is a threat
against me my Empire my money right now
people are going to be able to talk and
find out all the lies that I told them
people are going to find out all the
horrible things I did to them red alert
right now we need to shut Twitter down
get all the advertisers and again Elon
Musk has actually addressed this he
talked about doing a subscriber based
model he talked about changing the
financial aspects of of Twitter so so he
sees this this attack coming as well but
we gotta understand here there's very
powerful people right now that are going
to be looking at Twitter as a direct
threat against their hegemony on the
narrative on the conversation on the
truth that's the Brutus metaphor of what
you're saying earlier the longer Elon
holds this hot potato the more of a
Target he becomes so he needs to release
come out forceful make these radical
changes and overwhelm them which is what
the left does when they're in power you
can make a comparison when Trump was in
his office for the first four years he
he dithered he dallied he could have
done a lot more things until he waited
to the last few months which was sad but
you make a good point from previously it
really goes back to if you build it they
will come they could have this hissy fit
they can pull out their money but if
he's truly going to turn this into a new
revolutionary platform move it away from
this Advertiser beholden structure into
something more we Chad better Tech
better features and the masses come back
to Twitter what are they going to do
they're not going to be able to hold off
for long because they're missing a
massive Market uh for for potential
advertising you know Supply so they're
not going to turn that down someone's
super it's me super chatted Elon needs
to charge five dollars to tweet at Trump
only make the rest ad free one trillion
a year profit all the Trump reply guy is
like well if you tweet at Trump it's
five dollars and then they would just
fund the whole the whole platform that's
it so you monetize it there you go it's
it's as simple as that huh I asked Bill
ottman if you wanted to Federate mines
with Twitter parlor Rumble and Truth
social and he was like hell yeah except
not the fediverse because of the
limitations and it was just a vague
interaction we had but he pointed at
Noster which I mentioned at the
beginning of the show n-o-s-t-r it's a
it's a protocol
um let's see and you can go to Noster
it's on github.com Noster Dash protocol
uh so I think what's gonna happen is all
these networks are going to be able to
interoperate like you'll be able to see
truth social content while you're logged
in because the problem with the feta
versus it doesn't have a universal login
it's going to aggregate everything yeah
yeah with fediverse you'd have to log
into like Mastodon to view everything
that's Federated and if Mastodon wants
you banned you can't view anything
anymore because you're mastodonic I
can't write off All Tech because all
Tech definitely pushed Twitter and
obviously he's pushing Elon it's led to
a lot of the tech features they've begun
to release so it's done its job I hope
elon's you know revolution of Twitter
doesn't totally you know negate
everything that you guys are building
and others are building I thought we can
take it offline too like we could have
web mesh networks locally with this
software with this Twitter and Minds all
this stuff where like I can tweet at you
if you're nearby without having any kind
of Internet just on our devices yeah
look I think Elon tries to communicate
much more and much more quickly because
I do not see any logic or Reason Why
certain accounts like the Babylon b
haven't been reinstated more importantly
uh James Lindsay he got banned for
calling someone a groomer who was you
know literally a groomer he's not
insulting lgbtq people he's literally
targeting he was calling out somebody
who was grooming kids he was banned for
that there are many things that Elon
could have walked in and snapped his
fingers
if his complaint is that it took him a
year to make an edit button then it's
like okay I get it we're on we're on day
one and a half or whatever but that's
why communication is important cat turd
tweeted
it's it's elon's taking over nothing's
changed Eon said I'll be digging into
this more today then he comes out and
says we won't do anything anything until
our committee happens
are you kidding okay dude look I feel
like it's it's
if Elon doesn't immediately just pull
out the lightning bolt of Zeus and throw
it he's going to keep sitting down
having conversations like Dorsey I'll
put it this way
the old Trope about the president
getting elected and you know he's on the
campaign Trail saying I'm gonna end the
wars and I'm gonna get the price of gas
down then he gets into office the CIA
the FBI DHS they all slam all these
folders in his desk and say you can't
and here's why and then instead of
pulling a trump where Trump goes excuse
me excuse me I don't know I don't care
get this out of here I'm doing what I
want we're getting the troops out and
then they all lost their mind and tried
to get rid of him elon's going in there
and and I worry and I don't know it's
only been day one but he may go in and
pull a traditional presidential Trope in
that he goes I'm gonna unban everybody
and I'm gonna do these things he sits
down and they go okay now this
Advertiser does 300 million per year
they said that if Trump is on the
platform they won't advertise it anymore
if you don't have that money we lose
this core of the company and then this
company says we don't like Milo they
complained if you have him on and then
elon's gonna go okay
so if I have these 10 people banned we
keep all this money and the platform
keeps working all right well I guess
I'll compromise there I had a
conversation with the tech CEO
a long time ago of a big big social
media platform and they told me
it's a guy and he said Tim
I don't want to ban these people but if
I don't ban this guy
everyone loses the platform so what am I
supposed to do and I was like I don't
know grow a pair of balls call the bluff
of these companies look them in the eye
and say if you don't want to advertise
on the platform that everyone is on and
you want to make yourself irrelevant by
all means Will Wheaton is hanging out
who knows where these days he's on
Twitter or on Mastodon but I'm sure he
look he's looking for someone to talk to
you can go hang out with them if you
want to be in our house where the party
is at then you accept there are people
here who say things you don't like if
Elon doesn't just assert that
immediately we're spiraling back into
the same problem right the fact that
he's saying we need a diverse board to
decide this I'm not like there we go
again I heard the same thing from Dorsey
three years ago and Elon saying the same
thing again I said it was a bad move I
stand by it and I like how he's
obviously being very responsive and the
Twitter replies but Jack was the same
and exactly went on Rogan he did all the
song and dance and nothing changed so
he's going to repeat history and it's
going to lead to the doubt the continued
downfall of Twitter and again
but this is why the the Twitter exec's
cashed out right they were like all
right it's all yours buddy yeah enjoy I
have hope
because let time tell yeah it's still
early on here when Jack was involved it
was a public company and he didn't have
control of it at that point anymore he
was just kind of saying what he wanted
but Elon has full control at this point
I mean which means there's no FBI and
the things like that right legal he
can't do illegal things obviously but
he's got right he's got the reins and
he's got his foot on the gas the stakes
are so high we have to hold his his feet
to the fire to the coals just that the
stakes couldn't be higher this is a
civilizational type of thing we're
dealing with this is the Public Square
this is the means of communication the
the way to disseminate any kind of idea
so it's not just any other business it's
not a retail operation it's not a car
company it it's really goes beyond that
maybe not on the financial side but
certainly on the civilizational side
here's here's what's gonna happen he's
convening this this diverse Viewpoint
moderation ecumenical council and here's
what's going to happen if he does have
progressives on it they're going to say
Do not reinstate Alex Jones he's a
violent authoritarian fascist bigot Elon
is going to tell going to have to tell
them to screw off or he's going to have
to listen to them
either way what's the point of doing the
counsel
if you got to tell him to screw off
anyway because you know what their
answer is going to be then uh just unban
Jones if you are not going to then
you're just listening to the Mob there's
there's no middle ground here there's no
magical world where the people who have
been who burned down cities for in the
George Floyd rise and then lie about in
the media there's no world where they
are like peacefully negotiating with you
because the left governs in the private
sector in the public sector by their
ideology and their ideology will dictate
their actions and then you have you know
good intention people like Elon coming
into and they're like you know we'll
make a committee we'll make a council
let's let everyone hear it out and it
doesn't go anywhere I'll I'll take the
win for now I don't want to be you know
total Negative Nancy on this one it's
been good I'm just genuinely confused as
to why he didn't unban The Babylon bee
immediately it would have been big press
it would have been good I can imagine a
few things
the reason why Twitter bans the people
they do is because advertisers demand it
that's it because the left is good at
organizing they don't just send
complaints themselves they complained to
they complained to advertisers and say
we will come for you these advertisers
know yeah they mean it they'll come with
firebombs bricks signs they'll cause us
damage they'll smash the windows out
let me tell you if you own a storefront
in Portland
well I'll say Berkeley all the Berkeley
storefronts have anti-trump or they did
not like and woke signs why if in the
middle of the night someone throws a
brick what can you do call the police
you and the police are going to say
they're gonna say sorry it happened to
you let us know if anything else happens
see ya what are they gonna do they're
going to launch a big investigation to
hunt down a person who ran by with a
rock never gonna happen but you're gonna
pay thousands of dollars or however much
to fix that gigantic window so then
everyone just says it's easier just to
put the sign up and mind my own business
and this is what happens with big
corporations let's say you sell Saudi
pop and then you get 50 emails from
antifa from BLM and they say we can
cause you so much damage you will regret
Crossing us and they go I don't care
about this just fine we'll we'll stop
advertising on Twitter it doesn't make
enough money for us anyway then Elon or
whoever's at Twitter sees that come in
look we're getting tons of complaints
about Milo we don't want to advertise in
your platform anymore and they go look
either we ban Milo or we lose the whole
platform and then they do and that's the
chain of events unless someone is
willing to say it's either this or
nothing it will not change and I mean
that didn't happen yet if it does he
deserves to be called out right I'm a
little bit more optimistic we're still
early time tell time what do you mean we
we it's been seven months we all know
the Babylon bee is unfairly locked up
lock locked out of there yeah
there's an election in a week
and Elon Musk finally secures the
platform and if anything he could do is
say my friends The Babylon be shouldn't
have been banned I already know that's
true I am going to remove this lock as
for other people I don't know I am going
to need some time to work through this
I'd accept that and the counter argument
to which you just stated before is that
the Twitter has been thoroughly wokified
for years and it's an unprofitable dying
platform it's been continuously making
bad mistakes on the tech front it's
losing users most of its users are Bots
they've tried the fully woke model and
it's not working from a financial
perspective so if he is going to be
intimidated by the supposed Financial
repercussions of allowing more free
speech on Banning The Babylon B I think
is back oh maybe go on Twitter right now
I think they're back I just he's
watching I think Babylon B is back right
now I haven't seen any tweets I just
looked at a minute ago and it's just
it's like they are not backwards it was
locked so they weren't like the account
wasn't erased or anything it was just
locked until they
they can't get access to their account
to view or post tweets until they remove
the offensive tweet on Rachel Levine so
this is what keeps happening so which is
like literally like so many tactic that
they do regret take it back take it back
now you've been a bad boy I get dozens
of messages every day from people who
are like Tim Trump is back and I'm like
oh because they assume that Trump's
account shouldn't exist it's like no on
Instagram he can't post anything on
Facebook his account is there people
think because they can see it it means
they're back so I hear this non-stop
every single time I I look I made my
point
um Elon waiting on this I know it's been
a day so okay I don't know I'll calm
down a little bit we'll see we'll see
over the week if we're gonna get any any
any any
um meaningful changes
I I just I I really need
I think I don't understand why why we
didn't see anything the move is to do it
all at once and you say in a sweeping
move all accounts that have been banned
or or locked that didn't violate U.S
state law are hereby reinstated agreed
yeah and he could he could do that today
and probably take the weekend to do it
and then on Monday morning or or but
he'll do it he'll do a 4 20 on Sunday
and again it makes it so much harder for
them to respond the concern is that big
advertisers like this one are saying
will pull our ads and if there's no
money coming in there's no Twitter but
unless someone breaks the addiction
cycle of this broken psychotic machine
it will keep happening what's Twitter
blue you know how much money they're
pulling in from Twitter it's like three
bucks a month but here's the issue you
want to know why antifa is allowed to
organize illegal activity on the
platform and get away with it because
Twitter is scared of them because the
big advertisers are scared of them
that's why they don't get banned because
they're the look I say it all the time
does Twitter headquarters pre-elon were
they ever scared that like Dave Rubin is
is going to lead a bunch of classic
liberals with pitchforks and torches to
their doorstep no are they concerned a
bunch of black masked lunatic
Psychopaths with bricks and molotovs and
guns would yeah because they do so
Twitter Facebook YouTube Every
Advertiser they are scared to death that
one day they'll walk outside their
building and some guy will hit him in
the face with a brick and it's not going
to be a conservative so we can ban the
conservatives because they won't do
anything about it anyway but we better
not cross anti-fun the extremists left
it's still happening right now and
you're presenting a broader political
dilemma is that it's this asymmetrical
political fight where the conservatives
or the right wing are fighting with
their hands tied behind their back and
the left wing are bringing guns to a
knife fight or not even to a fight at
all and they're just playing to win they
don't care about the substance they
don't care about the style they don't
care about anything else they're there
for one thing one thing only power power
dynamics and advancing their ideology
and they don't care about any of the
nice cities associated with you know
councils Etc I would not be surprised
okay look it's a victory that Elon
bought the platform we cracked the Louis
XII I know I know I know but I'm I'm
just I'm eager to make sure this goes in
the right direction and his his
announcement about some some diverse
Viewpoint counsel sounds just like Jack
Dorsey just like vijayagada it sounds
exactly like what they were saying based
on that
I wouldn't be surprised I'm not saying
it's highly probable if come April there
is uh you know me sitting with Elon and
Joe being like Elon why won't you do
this we had this antifa person and
elon's gonna be like you know we're
going in and we're trying to make sure
we're doing it fair blah blah blah blah
I'm not saying it's highly probable I'm
not saying I would bet on that I'm
saying I wouldn't be surprised based on
wanting a diverse Viewpoint committee or
whatever I'm like that right there was
just like oh that's more BS start a
crypto token start a utility token Elon
a Twitter token what if he puts Doge on
Twitter yeah use Doge and then you can
pay users with dogecoins so here's
here's another strange phenomenon we can
talk about uh here's my social blade for
my my Twitter account look at me with
one million 361 000 followers thank you
for following me I I just tweet nonsense
I've lost 5 000 so far this month but
that's up 22 percent and and probably
because I've been you know I just tweet
kind of stupid nonsense but uh today
I gained 4264 followers what about you
Luke you gained a bunch of followers I I
did and a whole bunch of Engagement a
whole bunch of likes that I never had
before I'm gonna check right now and so
probably maybe they have started with
the lower level accounts and they're
working their way up and these are some
of the well he's you know he said he's
not he didn't make any changes he said
no changes have happened Luke you gained
859 I mean you've been consistently
gaining a good amount of followers this
past week but today you've gained more
than uh double what you gained yesterday
yeah 859 followers
and check this out look at this Twitter
the Great Purge has begun Twitter users
report losing thousands of followers as
Elon Musk formally takes over the
platform and sets to work on bot
cleaning he says he hasn't changed it's
uh you know like the content moderation
but take a look at this Kate Smith says
wow I lost a few hundred followers
overnight welcome to Twitter Elon people
are saying I lost followers one person
with the Ukrainian flag in their profile
I lost 50 followers
yeah unit I think said it before I'll
say it again
Twitter was propping up fake accounts to
make it look like the left was more
prominent than they were because the
right is more prominent and they were
Banning people on the right and Shadow
Banning them to make it seem like they
were less prominent they put their thumb
on the scale and this is so important
when you talk about politicians you talk
about their staff you talk about the
decisions that happened in Washington
they see Twitter as really what's the
Viewpoint of the vast majority of people
their constituents what's public what's
the Public's you know view on things but
it's a completely manipulated you know
audience pool I mean if it was a
congressional district it'd be like a d
plus 70. it's not something that exists
in the real world and it's all about the
perception that they're creating the
illusion they're creating and it's not
just the likes it's not just the follows
it's even the comments I mean you see
those those memes that go around where
it's all the same comment that's being
shared every time a major news cycle
hits and I'm glad he's going after it
it's also noticeable it's these
left-wing accounts claiming they're
losing followers which were Bots a few
weeks ago it was right-wing accounts I
mean they lost followers were real
people they're saying it's people
quitting the platform in protest just so
what because the 4 000 followers a bunch
of conservatives joining the platform I
don't believe it because Twitter
recommends leftist accounts not writing
account first leftists they'll never
follow through on their threats to quit
they never move to Canada for example so
I doubt that they actually you know are
quitting Twitter right now so it's
certainly Bots that was something he
brought up and that was something that
came up you know when the evaluation
talks when they were first you know in
in talks to buy it was the bot issue I
mean that that's a fundamental issue it
could be that Elon immedi went after the
Bots first thing he did his first task
yeah yeah and so you know I'll say maybe
I want to see some changes faster than
he can go about it maybe Elon is like
the Bots got to go first and advertisers
are on board with that if we want to go
back to the finite because they want
real legitimate clean you know metrics
they don't want Bots or maybe just to
investigate to see what was going on to
see what the algorithm really was to see
how it was being manipulated to see who
was being punished for what I I think
there needs to be a long investigation
into what is essentially a very
potentially very illegal activities with
election interfering done by Twitter so
that that's a very serious uh you know
accusation but but only someone who just
acquired a company is going to be
looking into that right now as we're
speaking and we have to give them more
credit I do agree with you he's coming
into a company where the workforce that
exists is largely hostile I hate him
hates him he needs to fire 70 I think he
could probably fire 90 he is in a good
position that he could bring over some
loyal you know staff and support from
you know Tesla some of his Engineers
there Etc but it is going to take a
period of time just from a logistical
technical perspective to dig into this
and actually find out what's going on
behind the scenes how it can be
rectified how it can be and how do you
reduce it guys guys he's not going to
endear himself to the employees after he
just fired ligma Johnson
you know James Johnson was asking for it
how is this ligma Johnson
is on local news and a very serious
person this is real this is really his
name yes I think it was like no no it
was two guys it was like Rahul ligma and
Daniel Johnson were they they got fired
controls they showed up to Twitter HQ
with boxes that is awesome I think
they're gonna get hired they thought
they got fired automatically turns out
you're looking for a job I mean honestly
if you're a free software developer and
you want to get involved keep your eyes
on Twitter because he's going to be
hiring or it can just be a community
project he's going to be fired he's
going to be opening up a lot of
promotions but the thing is I don't
think Twitter needs I don't know what
they have 5 000 employees I mean if
you're running a free software
decentralized Network you need the
world's Community to be involved I want
and you don't need to pay them there's
so much debt can I can I can I can I
show you this guys parag agrawal's
salary was 30.4 million in 2021. Ned
Segal was 18.9 million Vijaya was 17
million Sean Ed get his composition was
unclear he was the one who had to be
escorted out of the building which is
really interesting so uh what is this a
former CEO Sarah person that was handed
a 11.2 million as part of musk's house
clearance I want you to think about
30.4 million dollars and I'd like to ask
you what does what do you do with that
money what do you do with it I was going
to say what they did for it but no I
mean he's working a full-time job which
is very like he runs Twitter I know
being the CEO it's a very it's a high
level job of a very large company it's
just insane to me that these people like
couldn't get an edit button done in a
year but they were given 30 million
dollars well the pay wasn't based on the
merits or the financials or anything
quantitative it was based on loyalty to
the regime and the regime's you know
Doctrine and what they were trying to
push to this platform and the social
engineering they wanted to use the
platform for and they were you know only
willing participants in that so they
were paid handsomely for doing a job
well done but it's not based on any you
know basic profit or loss model of a
traditional business it's based on
loyalty to the regime and that's why
this gentleman uh will be spending that
30 million somehow I have no idea though
30 million dollars to not be able to get
an edit button done in a year
that's just it's it's incredible I don't
think people truly understand what 30
million dollars means he wouldn't be
able to spend that if he tried wasn't
there like a dozen real engine I'm
making the numbers up but there was an
extremely small number of real engineers
and the entire structure of the
workforce was like a reverse pyramid
where it was those 12 supporting this
massive bloated you know pension scheme
at Twitter effectively and it was like
these few Engineers that were doing all
the work and everything else was just
you know corporate fluff and councils
and committees and you know diversity
leaders whatever it is yeah yeah I don't
think the hardware was the was the
majority of the people there are
probably people that are like how do we
handle the crowd kind of people right
trust and safety it's like so orwellian
it's all like an extension of HR it's
all just these these positions that
exist to perpetuate their own positions
they're not actually fundamentally doing
any real work I will say like you said I
don't know maybe there were incredible
developers across the board there was a
meme that came out that said uh you know
musk fires half of Twitter replaces it
with one hard-working Indian engineer
yeah yeah that's basically what it is he
could do the job of 3200 people right
yep exactly that sounds about right it's
all emo pushing jobs you know they send
an email they're gonna Circle back and
uh that that concludes the day all right
guys the thing about uh the compensation
that really gets me is that
I would be willing to bet
a substantial sum myself that you the
average viewer could do his job
not kidding
what knowledge does he have where he was
like it was mismanaged it was managed so
poorly the company was struggling it was
basically failing the this is just there
there is an elite class in this planet
it's always been the case they do
nothing they get everything but they
think it's unmerited in uh 2018 there
were roughly 4 000 Twitter employees
three years later 2021 or four years
later I guess there were 75 someone from
4 000 to 7 500. now almost doubled the
amount now that's the user growth which
I think if you factor out Bots I don't
know what it is but it's probably
stagnant if not you know a downward
Trend but at least if you factor out
Bots which may not be possible all right
let's find out yeah people are pointing
out that Kanye's Twitter account is back
and um Elon pointed out that's an
automatic thing that has nothing to do
with him you know oh it was like one of
those seven day things or whatever right
and so it was a kind of just turned back
on you should just take credit I just
you know it it really is shocking and
and it's unfortunate I I would be
willing to bet additionally that if I
took that
30 million dollars in one year 30 and
gave it to a random viewer of this show
they would build something more
substantial more historical and better
than anything he did that's just I
really can't stand Silicon Valley and
and that machine crony capitalist BS I
just I I despise it so much it's an
incentive structure for loyalty you keep
these guys operating against their own
company's best interests because they
know the payout will be greater than
whatever else they could get through
normal channels and and I guess he got
60 million dollars to get fired
parag yeah you got 60 million I think
someone in fact check it real quick well
in a way I think golden parachute was uh
60 million I was wondering what what
Elon would do I'm glad that he gave them
payouts I mean I don't think you can
ethically just say like goodbye now
everything that you were earning is set
to zero so but that's a lot of money my
man ethically 60 million bucks uh let's
see I got this uh the total value they
say in gardening was 120 million dollars
in Golden parachutes
do they break it down
uh here we go what is it uh
no okay 8.4 tiger wall doesn't sound
right this cycle goes back to the FED
30. 4.8 million to vajayagare why would
she get more than the CEO that seems
strange
whatever he's been there longer she's a
woman
well she's been there longer so maybe
that's it but I just it's just so crazy
man I'm looking at the user growth the
numbers from 2018 they had 335 million
monthly active users but then two years
later they had 330. so I mean the
actually down five million so the staff
went up and the users went down that's
right that's a great it's a great setup
yeah the staff went from yeah almost
went from 4 000 to 5500 while the daily
user it pays to be the thought police
you know so in your centering speech
when you're going after people for
political ideas and expression and act
like you're fighting the Germans during
the 1930s you got to be paid a lot of
money to play pretend for that long for
for that much for for that much of a for
that big of a circumstance so I'm not
crazy of an act exactly yeah you know
and and you know you gotta pay for
private security if you're in Silicon
Valley you know a lot of crazy people
out there running around with hammers
and deranged individuals and people
throwing poop at you and people you know
syringes people giving themselves the
the vaccine in the streets all the time
so I want to see rumble's headquarters
because I'm thinking about Twitter's HQ
was very lavish yeah I got a tour of
them is it all like Bachelor style
apartment
it it it it it it it's surreal because
it looks like a cartel house like right
on the water it's like it's it's huge
it's Christmas treated you with like a
scotch and a cigar and he was like
where's the Lamborghini I'm like this
looks like a scene out of Scarface it
really does I don't know I'm like where
where's the you know where's the rifle
was it that's better than a modernist
soulless building in Silicon Valley with
their cafeteria and absolutely and it's
not that big it's but it it that's what
I'm wondering how many floors two floors
oh see that's modest you don't we didn't
have a huge I mean that is a massive
amount of overhead not that many rooms
either you just don't need it not with
social media man you don't need big
buildings it's it's a it's all about
servers and server placement which
ideally will have that stuff in orbit
because if we do take some sort of
asteroid uh contact that we're going to
need to preserve our our data and our
knowledge yeah but Ian the problem is
um how do you dissipate the heat in
outer space well on on Big Data Centers
you would hit it with laser like laser
cooling laser cooling like if you hit
something with a laser it should move
heat that way move heat where off along
with the laser like the laser will carry
the heat I see I see what you're saying
so the laser goes through it and then
actually transfers energy out correct if
if we could do direct thermal uh
conversion into light and then beam it
away that would work that's that would
be crazy I'm glad you're my friend
that's a cool idea it's pretty cool I
mean for right now yeah actually that's
interesting but the servers are going to
generate heat we can try and recapture
heat but it's got to go somewhere
because the ambient heat we can't
control perfectly the efficiency
wouldn't be there yeah I should just
write things on Stone just go back the
servers operate by a guy reading the
code and typing in the ones and zeros
manually yeah yeah let's see yeah in 27
years you'll get this tweet out Chris
pavlovski CEO of Rumble and Elon have
been I don't know if they the two of
them directly have been in talks but
Chris reached out to him on Twitter
about a month ago I was like hey you
want to get involved because I'm a big
fan and Elon was like all right and then
now I hear they're working on like
because Chris is a server guy elon's a
satellite guy
Twitter needs a video component Twitter
needs something that that could either
be a tick tock or another Periscope or
another Vine they need that they don't
have that what if you really what if
Elon does succeed with with X and
Twitter becomes a place where you've got
a wallet uses crypto you can post videos
you can write stories you can make
tweets like it really becomes what Mark
Zuckerberg was hoping Facebook would
become the American WeChat and then I'm
gonna be critical of it and skeptical of
it because of how powerful and
all-encompassing it will be no as of
right now I'm optimistic when I see Bill
Gates and other establishment figures
attacking him but but when it becomes
too mainstream that's when I'm gonna
have questions well no one thought that
Myspace was going to fail or even
Snapchat and now it looks like Facebook
the platform itself is pretty much going
nowhere so who knows we'll get a
revitalization story at a time if I was
if I was a billionaire I would do what I
would call The parag agrawal Challenge
and I would give 30 million dollars to a
random person for for an investment
project obviously there's rules you'll
just get the money it would be an
investment not income it would be we
credit we create a company we put 30
million in It Go
and then we would see at the end of one
year what we have
it would be I think it would be
hilarious because like you could take
your average like contractor and they'd
be like oh I built a bunch of houses
like wow houses that's really amazing
parag what did you do in one year well I
was running Twitter and we could get an
edit button done it's like I'm sure he
was doing something you know what I mean
but based on that project Veritas video
where the guy is like I work four hours
a week or something like that I really
doubt any of them are doing anything wow
yeah you want people that are committed
to 40 plus hours a week at least because
it's about organization at that level if
you have 30 million like I could pay you
30 million but if you're only working
eight hours a week and there's no other
employees well you've seen those viral
Tick-Tock videos right the girl walking
around like here's my day in the office
yoga it's really stressful red wine on
tap right so here's here's the secret
investors ask people they say
um ask you a question
if tomorrow you woke up and you had a
million dollars in the bank account cash
clean ready it was it was legitimate
deposit what would you do
what would you do Gavin
I would just buy property you'd buy
property yeah a rental that's not a
terrible answer they're not making any
more land what about you Ian what would
you do I think I would buy a house at
this moment yeah it depends at this
interest rate are you crazy although I
hear the housing markets cash it's like
cash purchase uh what would you do if
you woke if you woke up and you had a
million dollars just in cash buy a whole
bunch of employees and expand operations
Buy employees like slaves no but that's
Take It Outside
no no that's not I set the box your
guys's answer would never get you an
investment oh yeah I'm not looking oh oh
you want it oh yeah well yeah it doesn't
matter if you think you're getting
investment or not the question I mean I
could pay four people 100 Grand okay but
here's what people are looking for
they're looking for someone who
naturally wants to expand operations not
someone who needs to be told to do it so
if you said I'd buy a house they go
that's really cool nice meeting you and
if they went to a homeless guy and he
goes like I'd love to start a company
now just we're gonna make bird houses
and I'm gonna hire 100 people and have
the biggest birdhouse back you're here
we'll give you the money if it could be
72 000 for server space on AWS while I'm
paying 60 grand for nine employees three
of which will be
working for the six others two people
will be resp you know that kind of thing
but they're like oh God yes plug it in
but you need to understand this that
most people will be like oh well I
didn't know you meant if I was going to
do a business I don't I mean what's your
first priority and you guys clearly said
property not a bad answer because
property is an investment most people
say like I go to Hawaii I take my family
out those people will never see a dime
from an investor but what what what so
even even with what we're doing here at
timcast the biggest challenge is
Personnel is finding people who want to
work on something not people who want a
job people who want a job tend to just
you know quiet quit do the bare minimum
so when you're trying to invest in
someone to give them a substantial
amount of money you want to go to
someone and say if you had a million
dollars what'd you do it's like oh man
you know I've always wanted to launch my
own comic book distribution Network and
if I just had the capital we'd get it
going but I've already got the books I
just need to figure out how to get to
these you're hired here's the money have
fun good luck what do you find is the
bulk of cost when you're running
operations labor almost like labor
specifically uh in-house labor out of
House labor it's all the same Labor's
labor people are the most expensive
thing by far yeah yeah but I mean do you
do you end up spending 20 15 of the of
the cost on like outsourced labor like
legal stuff like that marketing things
like that what do you what do you mean I
just wonder just just in general like if
you spend it mostly on in-house
employees or if of course of course most
of it's an in-house I mean we have a lot
of contractors and then we have legal
and then we have construction and then
we have external marketing and PR
there's a lot of stuff that we don't do
in-house because it doesn't make sense
to do and uh most of the cost is like an
employee working for the company you
prefer to do that I mean in-house it's
not so much prefer as just like
it's it's more like if there's a a wavy
field you know let's say this table was
wavy and you poured water on it the
water would pull in the lowest point you
know what I mean it's it's not like I'm
I'm saying we should do contract labor
or something it's like that's how it's
done I'm not gonna hire a lawyer to work
for this company you know what I mean
I'm gonna contract a legal a law firm
who can handle it specialization yeah
yeah like the people we need to hire the
people need to be here all the time
specifically like a video producer an
audio engineer but like Vice head
in-house counsel you know they they had
a room with like two or three lawyers in
it they were really really big maybe
we'll get to that point you know but uh
you know yeah anyway my point uh
ultimately about the cash stuff is
I look at a lot of the people in Silicon
Valley people these companies and they
should not be getting paid what they're
getting paid because they don't care
about the product they don't care about
the growth they don't care about the
mission they don't believe in Merit they
believe in like I deserve to be here and
then they do nothing and so it burns to
the ground it's a broader problem in
Corporate America where you see these
these compensation packages are so out
of whack with what they actually deliver
and you know they make excuses they talk
about the scale of things Etc but at the
end of the day you know it it still is
very much out of whack when you look at
what you mentioned before the growth in
terms of staff and employees and the and
the the decrease in actual users I mean
there's a yeah
increase in staff with no nominal growth
here's here's a secret if you want to be
rich go hang out with rich people that's
it goodbye I'll tell you why the in like
the Palisades in Brentwood in California
and L.A you know these places yeah
beautiful these are the places where if
you're just friends with one of these
wealthy Hollywood Elites you can be like
you know I sell this fancy lotion it's a
hundred dollars a bottle they'll say oh
I'd love some and then it's it's Jergens
in a little bottle and and this is the
way it works I've known people who who
are like oh I make jewelry and I'm like
how much do you make per year it's only
a couple hundred thousand per year and
I'm like for making Joy yeah but I have
a very select clientele of Hollywood
Elite it's like okay because you know
Rich Hamptons too because you're friends
with rich people and they want to buy
from you they just have money and give
it to you you're rich there you go
there's a whole social like class
absolutely between the Hamptons and
Hollywood whatever that that feed off of
that usually you know they fall into
like the wine mom you know category of
in terms of demographics it's
unfortunate when people turn to alcohol
when they get bored um they beat the
game and they just start getting drunk
every night the only day difference on
average in my opinion maybe not not
necessarily but there is a there is a
there's a fine line between someone with
a carpet a a sheet thrown on the ground
with a bunch of jewelry strung about it
and they're sitting there smiling at you
saying one dollar necklaces and some you
know yoga wine Aunt who is making 300
000 a year selling necklaces to select
clientele in the Palisades it's just who
you know a four thousand dollar haircut
because you're worth it exactly and then
they're able to write that off on their
taxes I don't think you could write off
haircuts on your taxes thank God
depending on your industry
yeah entertainment so like Hollywood can
and this is the craziest thing if you're
if you're an actor in Hollywood all that
cosmetic stuff is a business expense and
I mean to be honest it kind of is it's
legitimate yeah you need to look a
certain way and whatever but it I I have
I have hung out with people who have
told me their jobs are just like oh you
know I I sell this that are otherwise
and I'm like and you make that money
half a million dollars or something
they're like well of course I get 20
Commission on all the products and my
clients are all very wealthy and I'm
like
it's like a Royal Court for like these
Aristocrats you got the jobs you got a
few people exactly Luke you mentioned
that you were you would expand
operations are you talking about for we
are change yeah and then uh just looking
at Solutions I think
um providing food that's not poison
um is is a good Big Industry that I
think has a lot of potential to also get
into that I would want to get into that
I'm kind of looking into getting into uh
and and helping people as much as they
can so like selling like Health product
health food uh maybe not even just
health food maybe just normal regular
food you know yeah without seed oil
without high fructose corn syrup seed
oils and and all the you know forever
chemicals and microplastics and other
things that that just destroy Humanity
it has a green label on it and it says
it's healthy what are you trying to tell
me no no no you're wrong propagandize
let's put little styrofoam cubes in in a
plastic wrap and then put the
ingredients list you know on it and then
people they won't know the difference
anyway you know what I mean you'd see a
guy eating it
didn't they do an experiment where they
made a Rice Krispie with like sawdust
just a small amount of sawdust and
wanted to see if people could tell and
they couldn't it's basically equivalent
what they do to mostly have you looked
at parmesan cheese from the supermarket
oh yeah one of the ingredients is
cellulose yeah it's it might as well be
cardboard right it's indigestible plant
matter well yeah and they they talk
about oh it's it's like we have a
society where you're constantly having
to work out just to be the bare minimum
in terms of healthy you go to Europe you
look back in time you know the caloric
intake hasn't gone up it's it's the
quality of the food we're putting in is
trash and then we wonder why we're more
unhealthy so here we talked about this
the other day I went on uh we had Seth
weather's on he said I need to eat more
protein I said I ate like 100 grams in
one days you need 150 and I was like do
I and then I checked like a government
website it said 70 grams but it's
actually be eating 400 to 500 carbs and
then I was just thinking to myself I
couldn't eat that many carbs if I tried
well they also said eggs were bad they
said butter was bad they said everything
bad meat was bad it's like it's it's all
nuts whatever the government says don't
do the opposite do what tradition tells
you a tradition says eat a lot of meat
eggs butter let me let me tell you you
know those outright bars we have yeah
those have 24 grams of carbs in it so I
have to eat like what 20 of them to get
the 500 carbs they I couldn't I could
barely eat one of those protein but
Grant has protein in them but if I ate
if I ate 20 of them that's too much
protein 20 of them are you insane they
want you fat childless and on a really
manipulated Twitter that's their yeah
yeah yep and so I've been eating uh so I
I probably do need more protein to be
honest I I skate a lot exercise a lot
but it's just insane that that's what
people are told to eat
the whole system just seems completely
broken to me and we waste so much time
talking about health and exercise
instead of putting into other productive
things it's like we're so focused on the
bare minimum not being you know an obese
morbidly obese person you know these are
things 100 years ago you really have to
deal with and I'm not saying they had to
go out and hunt or gather and you know
hunt their food we had a balance you
know as recently as the 1970s you could
look at the charts it it backs it up but
we just have so much time and energy
wasted now into health food and just
returning to a normal seat like you said
that's not even Health Food it's just
normal food normal food that my grandma
used to eat that that we don't get to
eat right now because of a number of
different factors uh mono cropping is
another horrible element but but more
importantly you don't even need to look
at the science of the data look at the
photos look at the people a couple
decades ago look at the people now it's
terrifying whenever you go to like a
beach or a public park or a theme park
you look around and if you start paying
attention you're like holy freaking cow
there is a biological warfare being
committed on everyone mostly in this
country though because you go to other
countries it's not nearly as bad you see
that photo from the 50s where everyone's
just fit looking yeah so weird yeah you
didn't go to gyms they didn't they
didn't count the calories now Disney is
doing that fat chick film right where
it's like you can be morbidly obese but
it's okay it's sort of it feels like
we're dancing around a Renaissance but
if not for the the overweight the
Obesity crisis what's all these
distractions because we have to relearn
all these basic things we used to know
and be able to do innately you know just
be healthy now it's like this is an
active thing we have to do to be healthy
they call it organic food organic means
carbon based all food is organic right
but but they created a special word for
what food is supposed to be I love it
it's like organic food means like food
right so we should actually we should we
should change this chemical food and
food right so it's like I got milk is it
chemical milk or is it milk altered it's
chemical language that's all language
that's language language Warfare I mean
even look at schools it's like public
school it's a state school or it's
mechanic I like that you point out that
yeah it means like carbon based so think
about school think about what they're
saying though when it's not organic
they're basically saying it's like a
petrochemical or something yeah like
it's not that's what we cook with we
cook with oils that used to be used for
mechanical and Industrial purposes they
just slightly Twisted them up there was
a whole incident that happened I think
in Spain Madrid and in the 80s or 70s
where they all got some toxic oil
syndrome because the food that they were
cooking with was like this this canola
oil that was basically meant for like
industrial engine oil you know gutter
oil is oh in China yeah where they they
scoop it out of the sewers and then they
filter it out boil it and cook with it
and then you eat it on the street that's
pretty much what most of our food is
that's everything you have in a
restaurant anyway that's exactly they
don't change that deep fryer every time
they cook something and it's not schools
it's indoctrination centers thank you
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com all
right we're going to read some of these
super chats
Jeremiah dobler says the Paul Pelosi
incident is yet another example of
Democrats not knowing what they let out
of the bag catering to their Progressive
Wing if look look the guy was a green
party dude but he also was a crap you
know he posted Q stuff he was a
conspiracy guy he had a pride flag
you know I it is what it is yeah you let
a summer of violence happen that's going
to affect everyone in the world yep
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim Poole says
I don't know why anyone follows me on
Twitter as he melts the fragile adult
baby minds of cult leftists screeching
about a red verify badge bro this is
going to be fun and we are here for it
yeah I tweeted so I tweeted um
that Elon should make a new verification
badge except it shows that you're a
fascist and it's red
then I tweeted again when he when he
bought it the same exact thing but but I
said except it shows that you're a
communist and it's red and you can't
remove it by choice
and they're like losing their minds
they're like he wants to Patches
they should review a lot of the
verification the people that are
verified and the whole verification
process because that's another you know
blame tool for manipulation yeah a
verification originally was anyone could
apply for it right and it was just you
submit your ID and they say okay you are
you so you are you're good and then they
decided to make it a um an endorsement
right and it was funny because they were
like we don't see it as an endorsement
and then they literally they took James
O'Keefe's away right it's like what they
wouldn't give one to Julian Assange and
it's violating uh 230 I mean they're
editorializing I mean it's another
example of it they're allowed to
editorialize under 230. they're not
violating it oh true but they wouldn't
so they but then don't they lose
protection nope no that that's that's
what it that's what that's what
conservatives want it right but that's
uh that's funny you're like section 230
basically says they can do whatever they
want without without without liability
right it's insane so we're repealing
it's bad it should just say if you
engage in moderation of any kind you
lose immunity you take an editorial
stance right
all right let's read some more
Saint miles has anyone else noticed the
U.S Capitol Police were on the scene
that's that's right they were
not Danny McBride says Ian will you be
my dad sure I mean metaphorically yeah
man metaphorically let's do it together
pay it forward and then you be someone
else's dad
okay gone fall says you guys should play
audio clip donations but only members
can and those audio clips have to be
reviewed before being shown on live
we've thought about a lot of things like
that but it's like a different show it'd
be like a call-in show Almost so we're
making plans for expanding and doing
something like that which would be fun I
think call and show would be really fun
to do but we'll figure it out maybe
maybe we'll do like Fridays yeah yeah
we'll have like from nine to nine thirty
we'll do like pre-screened Collins like
cool like recorded messages and then
we'll play them and then we'll respond
to him like you said it's a good idea
just because you can't really do a live
you turn you get someone on the air and
then they're like I'm a businessman then
you press play and then they start
saying a bunch of crazy things yeah
totally
okay okay where are we at where are we
at
oh man Doc Holliday says for once
someone else was hammered in the
Pelosi's house
too soon
that is clever though it is clever but
hey man this guy got seriously hurt I'm
that's that's horrifying that scares me
much healing love Paul yeah man not okay
for for you know you don't gotta like
somebody to be like I hope the dude is
okay so I feel about John fetterman man
I will start crying the other night I
just want to oh bro when I was watching
that debate I was it was it was hurting
watching that man yeah it's so sad and
and now it's it's just here we go the
left is saying fetterman's up the right
saying Oz is up and I'm like whatever
dude vote don't vote for the guy who
can't talk Oz is bad for I don't know I
don't like him it's he's not that bad
it's just it's kind of cringe we could
have done better but he's just fetterman
is just it's not unfair man gotta rest
yeah dude it's sad recover
Hudson Beaudry says longtime listener
first live stream in super chatter
listen to timcast on Spotify every day
at work huge question when is Raymond g
Stanley Jr coming on the show Good
Question he certainly bought and paid
his way here already several times
around we'll have to you know maybe some
people suggested we do like a fan
episode and we bring on a handful of
people and that are like the core fans
that are super chatting all the time
stuff I think it's a good idea we'll
figure something out we're also big fans
of Raymond g Stanley Jr because he's
super chats all the time and he has good
super chats and we like reading them
yeah
oh man some of these there's a lot of
a lot of these jokes
[Music]
Jeffrey grajik says the hammer was Paul
Pelosi's Hammer the guy took away from
Pelosi yes right I think that's I think
that's what that's what I heard
interesting he grabbed the ham and the
guy got it from him and started hitting
him oh my gosh yeah it's crazy dude
Pina Shay's helicopter tour saying
speakers house unguard it is pretty sus
just saying I don't disagree
come on all right Amos Moses says when
are you having your fellow shiraki
chiraki on you know Mr West Mr fresh by
himself he's so impressed did you even
see the test you got Deez MF Rosie Perez
good morning I have no idea what that
means it's a live from his tracks from
what from one of his tracks I forget
which one now who's tracks Kanye West oh
Kanye should we have Kanye on that's the
question yes yes
um I just don't have any contact for
Kanye West Kanye I'd love to talk to you
about stuff that'd be fantastic I would
love to have him on the show but um I've
reached out to a couple people
no response it's like how do you it's
like how do you get in touch with Kanye
West yeah you know what I mean I don't
know Kanye call me I have no idea
um I've I've tweeted at Elon Musk
several times he responds to some people
it'd be great to have Elon what's the
email if Kanye would want to reach out
to you
uh
is it like a booking email no
I don't know man that's probably why uh
have your people call my people or
whatever yeah he'd be judged it if he
wants he knows how to do it so I I think
it'd be awesome to have Elon on yeah I
mean Kanye Elon too yeah right now but
for right now Kanye is the guy to talk
to and I and I'm and I'm not you know
I'm not super interested in actually
talking to him about his tweets or
whatever because I'm like okay okay we
get it like it's been talked about a lot
I'd actually be interested in talking to
him about business yeah and uh you know
he mentioned that he's a billionaire but
they never call a billionaire they call
him a rapper now now he's saying he lost
two billion dollars overnight I'm
interested to hear about his business
like and and I'm sure a lot of people
want to hear that stuff too but the
politics of a lot of it would be
interesting to talk about I like what he
does what he's doing with schools yeah
Reinventing the education system yeah
yep
okay let's grab some more so we have a
lot a lot of hammer jokes
a lot of hammer jokes that's right they
drink a lot yeah they certainly do
all right all right
Terry Boyd says OMG I am a 62 year old
nudist long time Avid follower and
listen of Tim cast and a conservative
please do not associate nudists with
lunatics
being a nudist how often are you nude I
gotta know I'd imagine all the time yeah
wow but like
don't you want to be warm you know it's
like Ian's wearing a coat and a yeah
it's kind of great yeah it doesn't seem
like a sustainable lifestyle and you
know what if like you're going out and
you're worried about I don't know
briggins and bandits slashing you so you
have to wear thick Leathers as you carry
your wares from Rambles in the like how
do they go on dates how do they do dates
it's a lot of questions
yeah James dorpinghaus says Jordan
Peterson said the Earth's population
would Peak at 9 billion people and
decline from there also free speeches
back on Twitter love y'all well it's
actually not you know it's funny because
Elon was like comedy is allowed again
but then he said but I didn't change any
rules it's like okay so it's not
but um nine billion already declining I
wonder where is he saying that's the the
scientific models were saying that it's
going to be going up from 7 billion to 9
billion and then naturally going down
but now with such uh I forgot the
explanation to it but but
um that's what all the all the graphs
were predicting but now with a
depopulation agenda I think that number
is not going to be reached
uh I've seen those and my ques like my
thought process is
regardless of
that basically means people don't have
kids
you know so it's like at a certain point
people don't have kids why
and then and then what happens if people
aren't having kids just some people are
having kids I don't know it sounds weird
who gets to choose
and and it's gonna and you need to
consider it's not just like everyone
stops having kids it's for cultural
reasons the the loss of children will be
centered in certain areas so it may
actually be that an urban centers
population collapses but in rural areas
they're more likely to grow which makes
sense considering everything we've seen
already and if those models are correct
the population expansion would primarily
be in Africa where population growth is
still substantially higher than in uh
other parts of the world and that's the
history of human civilization the cities
collapse first then the Hill People and
the country people come in and rebuild
it From the Ashes they're saying the Pew
uh the Pew Research Center is saying
mainly because people are going to be
having less children yeah and this is
according to their research but they
never say is it because they want to
have less children or they can't have
more children for financial economic or
other reasons yeah simulation 115 says
Tim if you do 3 P.M solo live streams on
Fridays why don't you invite a single
guest through a video call to discuss
the topic also guest idea Chad Brooks he
is an Aussie creator that is building a
Star Wars alternative
um doing gas is difficult and even if I
so I did a live stream today instead of
my normal recorded segment and it was
because the news was rapidly changing it
was initially reported Twitter employees
were fired then I started recording and
then like a few minutes in breaking news
we were hoaxed it's a fake story and so
like I'll just start a live stream but
uh the segment's supposed to be just
discussing you know monologue through
the news doing a guest thing would be
very similar to this and it would be
hard to coordinate and so I don't know
but I might actually do uh Fridays on
youtube.com timcast 3pm live for like 30
to 40 minutes because I it's a lot
easier and honestly it's like easier
work were you doing super chats yeah
that's awesome was it fun talking to the
crowd and everything yeah but I only did
a few super chats because the goal is to
like talk about everything for a half an
hour and then be done for the podcast on
iTunes and Spotify for the Temple Daily
Show so I that's about two podcasts are
simcast IRL conversations and Tim pulled
a Daily Show monologue I found that one
of the things about social media and
working with a live audience is that if
you allow yourself to get derailed by
the audience and start responding with
the audience the whole show just becomes
about that instead of the message that
you're intending to which is why they're
there in the first place is for your
message that's why I hold super chats
till the end so that we can do our thing
and then on Friday I've done two of them
now with the rovi way being overturned
and then the Elon Musk stuff was just
rapidly changing so I might I might do
Friday live streams just because uh
Friday's a weak news day as it is people
yeah people who want to go out and do
stuff they want to work they don't want
to be at work they don't want to be
listening to the politics they want to
go out and party like Friday nights what
is what happens okay where are we at a
lot of people saying uh drunk drunk
drunk drunk drunk drunk okay drunk drunk
drunk Jerry Murphy says I'm an amateur
stand-up comic and was wondering if you
are looking to hire anyone that may help
write comedy skits or possibly write
humorous news articles
yes but um
it's it's a bottleneck hiring is a
bottleneck it's very difficult to do you
got to get stuff online get your comedy
out there so that it can be seen by
people that work with Tim or that know
Tim and then they'll be like Tim look at
this and that's if he likes it he'll be
like get that person out here yeah
Carter made a video Carter Banks who
does all her music he made a video being
like hey I make music hire me and then
like six months later we were like hey
look at this and then I we I emailed
them like you want a job and he was like
oh wow that was a long time ago and then
we hired him yeah he's fantastic he's
he's amazing yeah a lot of people are
like hey just let me do this and I'm
like I don't know if you can or will I
don't even know who you are I don't have
time to look into you but if you want to
work with me or Tim or anyone else show
me what you got show me show me what you
can do do it or do it by yourself and
then you know naturally yeah we'll find
it but but it's it's still not easy
because it's like
right now we're looking for cast Castle
stuff because we want to uh get cast
Castle rolling
um
we want to you know carve out the edges
what's the what's the soft what's the
word what phrase I'm trying to think
about I like it all we want to make the
show better
round it out yeah round it rounding out
the show rounding out the show I'm
looking for like graphic artists and
like video me makers and I and I contact
people I'm like hey are you available
for hire a lot of them are like no
so all right Bobcat says we've already
seen leaked faked videos used in court
Remember The Rittenhouse trial and the
AI rendering or the editing software
that's right that was crazy
they were like we use an algorithm to
enhance the video it's true it's like
wow dude it's not
TJ Raymond says fetterman had a rally
the day after the debate he yelled Oz
supported pardons for January 6.
officers died that day an outright lie
infuriating that's right and they know
they're lying because who cares they
want Power what do you do
they just lie lie lie lie lie
Charlie says Rittenhouse was almost
convicted with a deep fake drone video
because the prosecutor compressed a
video that backed up Kyle's story yeah
and we saw his folder showing he had the
software and stuff it was crazy
crazy corruption man jeez dude
I don't know it should have been
disbarred
they never investigated him over that
stuff they should have got him on the
stand and asked them like we're using
this editing software why did you have
it
it's crazy story dude
Twisted ninja says remember in the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial and the D.A Binger
deliberately tried showing evidence on
an iPad because the zoom showed what he
wanted and got an expert to say
interpolation doesn't change the video
they are evil yup
and it does
it has to fill in the gaps when you zoom
in so a computer algorithm generates
what they think is there you can't add
pixels
all right all right
Henry back to places instead of ads I
would pay three to five bucks a month
for a blue check
I mean you get extra features when
you're verified the edit for instance oh
that's verified that's for blue yeah
yeah verification allows you to like
look at other verified posts
specifically or something I don't know
it's very low level features look I know
it's really are you verified no it's
really easy to get verified guys all you
got to do is get hired by a major
international corporation that has
connections with Twitter's HQ who will
make a phone call to the people they
know there and tell them to verify you
and then you will be that's that's how I
got verified oh that sounds easy though
yeah okay good when uh when before I
worked at Vice there were people asking
Twitter like why wasn't I verified like
activists were saying hey Tim Poole is
in these magazines he's in these shows
he's featuring these news articles
everyone's highlighting his work every
time he covers big stories why isn't he
being verified and Twitter never
responded the point the activists were
making is that I was not a corporate
individual I was independent but I was
at like trials and protests and the
media was all using my footage
that's cause for verification so that
people know hey this is a guy that
people know as a journalist who produces
his content and is being featured widely
we should let people know that this is
you know who he says he is
I got hired by Vice and they went oh
well yeah here give me a second
get on the phone and then they were like
oh you're good you're terrified that's
how it works that's right not about what
you know it's who you know that's what
they would say in the entertainment
industry it's it's just true it's true
Sacrament says unban everyone on Twitter
and release a statement that all have
been given a second chance start fresh
fresh
yeah
you know maybe Rusty Shackleford says
y'all should have the United Utah Party
candidate Jay McFarland on the show
could be pretty wild with him being a
Liz Cheney apologist and all
oof
she's a Democrat though
you know Alexandra Rose says hey Tim
will the rooster image be available as
merch maybe a shirt sticker or flank it
is
go to timcast.com click store and you
will see stand your ground rooster
Roberto Jr there's posters there's
shirts there's little flags and uh
we're going to sell them and we're going
to fly the flag and I like it because
roosters are great and it's my rooster
Roberto Jr who uh uh I raised here at uh
at the Cass Castle
unlike uh Roberto who was purchased from
a farm now we love Roberto okay but he's
off at cocktown okay he's in charge over
there and his son Roberto Jr we actually
hatched along with Maggie and Bernie and
then uh we got they jumped around the
room and they were all small pooping
everywhere it was hilarious and now he's
a big he's a big man protecting a big
flock so proud of him it's funny I
thought Roberta was a lady we got a
bunch of hens it turned out one of them
was a man and then from there came the
rest that's right and then we got we got
uh my brother went and bought four
Jersey Giants one of them turned out to
be a boy
because they try to call them but they
don't always get it right so now we have
a Jersey Giant rooster which is going to
be nuts because they're huge very big
yeah but the biggest rooster I think
ever was a Brahma
like our our good friend Sarah avenberg
who is one of the chickens and he was
like three and a half feet tall like
looks like a raptor it's crazy he's a
massive thing with these huge lights did
you look it up the biggest biggest
rooster yeah the king of all poultry the
giant one
yeah but hey man I'll say it again the
noble rooster if there is a predator
coming towards the flock the rooster
will make a sound the hens will run and
he'll charge full speed at the Predator
knowing he will die
but if it means the girls get to run
away and survive he will do it this is
one of the French national symbols or
rooster yes it is and maybe that's
someone superchetta I don't know if
where it is it said that uh the the the
national bird was almost the rooster and
the turkey Ben Franklin wanted the
turkey but they were all like no we're
not that humble then let's do something
I don't like turkeys they're weird
looking and they make stupid sounds yeah
but when you look in their eyes no
chickens are funny it's like looking at
your grandmother turkeys freak me out
they're like aliens with a weird thing
on their face
because they could eviscerate you
because but they don't great places
though they have great plumage and I
don't know if people a lot of people
haven't seen wild turkeys they don't
look like the cartoon turkeys no not at
all like so you'll see the turkeys
outside and then they puff up and spread
their butt feathers or whatever and then
look like that picture but then
sometimes they compress right when it's
like oh look at that yeah the ladies
look compressed and they can fly too
yeah yeah turkeys fly
I saw we saw we were driving down the
road near Antietam and a flock of
turkeys launched in the air and flew
away a flock of turkey they can't fly
too far but they can fly yeah they flew
up and then flew into a tree somewhere
Ryan Ball says if the only thing Elon
does is change Twitter's color from Blue
to Pink I'd be happy watching the left
lose their minds over something so
meaningless would be Priceless agreed
I agree
Justine Jardine says I want to be there
when Trump's Twitter account is
reactivated and unbeknownst to him his
phone makes a Twitter notification sound
can you imagine the look on his face not
to mention the temptation
Trump will have to be on Twitter will he
come back he has to that's just it has
he publicly proclaimed he wouldn't come
back yeah he did yep I think that
Federation might be a better focus to
get truth social and Twitter to be
interoperable Trump is a wild card you
never know what he's going to do
literally so that's a fair point I mean
it it's it's he has to be on Twitter but
he might be like no no I won't do it so
it's good for him to be on Twitter it's
a good feedback loop for him and it
keeps him grounded all right he's
grounded
grounded it's uh it's just relative
DD Darius
says if Elon Musk unbanned the political
the media will call it election meddling
also I have a book done blood herring
and two on the way for a series let's
discuss publishing perhaps but uh we're
currently jammed up we have a book
coming out the tales from the inverted
world book is coming out soon we're
excited for that
would have liked to have gotten it out
for Halloween but it is what it is
ghosts of the Civil War is the book and
uh you can watch the full show season
two is on timcast.com become a member it
is Shane Cashman Went Down to Georgia
and he started investigating ghost
stories and the lost Confederate gold
and it's a wild Gonzo journalism Hunter
S Thompson meets The X-Files really
really cool stuff which is UFOs
conspiracies death threats they
threatened someone threatened to kill
him because they don't want because they
don't want people to know where the gold
went when when the surrender was
happening at a pet a padamax a potamax i
pronounce it Appomattox Appomattox way
off yeah that's right uh the gold was
stored in a chest they raided it and
took it and fled with it wow something
like that so look look at me I don't
know what I'm talking about but you can
read the story and and you'll figure it
out because Shane did a good did a good
journalism there
all right synthetic greed says maybe
it's the meetings is either he's trying
to limit the amount of leftists that
will leave or by the end he will set in
stone how to moderate
some people some people pointed out that
the diverse moderation council is
basically him saying to bring
conservatives in which makes sense he
wouldn't need to add leftists to a
company that's overwhelmingly leftist he
needs to hire Independents Libertarians
conservatives but like what do you do
because if he if he hires like a couple
like conservative guys the Libertarians
are going to be like come on dude you
know it's like how do you
I don't know man
all right all right what let's see Evan
Suarez says congrats Tim on enabling
violence on Paul Pelosi the guy was Q
Anon and a trumpy probably listened to
you Tim
thanks for your free money
uh he was he was right there at the
green party he voted green party just
because he's anti-government doesn't
make him inherently right or whatever
but uh if he's green party that is a
left position if someone is a Democrat
and complaining about Democrats and
they're saying we want the Democratic
party to be better but we don't like it
and they believe the government's
corrupt they're still a Democrat but but
we made that point because we believe in
Nuance that's why we mentioned that uh
the guy was just kind of crazy and all
over the place and it's what we've seen
from a lot of these crazies
that's what it is it won't matter though
because like you are saying he was a
queuing on trumpy that is what it is and
we put leftist because he was Green
Party
what are you gonna do about it
all right William Wallace Bower D
burkhoven III solution for Elon is to
use standing legal precedent from when
Trump blocked the lady trolling him they
ruled his tweet so important he couldn't
block anyone God Will Save Us regardless
yeah you can do that and be aluck we
have to restore the public forum
so you know we'll see
Justin mom desire says 30 million I
support my family on more than uh more
than 50k a year most people probably do
I think that's like the median wage
that's why I'm just saying like it is
shocking to me when I see Trevor no make
16 million dollars it's just absolutely
crazy that's money that just goes to him
into his pocket and I'm like what does
he do with that
you know 30 million dollars you could
not spend it like you could not
reasonably spend it there if you have
that kind of money you're probably just
like you hired a company to manage your
money for you that's you're at the point
where you saw Richard you're like you go
to Schwab or something and you're like
here's money I don't even figure it out
4.2 percent return on my investment but
that don't I mean I'm not your money
marketer but I don't it's BlackRock if
you give money that you're giving money
to Blackrock so be be aware start a
company start off you basically can buy
anything you want whenever wherever
there is no service there is there's
there's no service like basic service
that you cannot have and you don't even
need to be that rich to get like the
most expensive hotels that you go to New
York City we uh we we did a really cool
party once in New York after an event
and it was like I think 10 grand for
this this luxury Suite to have like a
bunch of people in it having dinner and
stuff ten thousand dollars it was like
35 40 people we had a bunch of food and
drinks and it was it was for an event 10
grand very very expensive
if you're making 16 million a year
you're farting that you don't even think
twice like what do you do with that
money that's it's just it's just my it's
crazy to me mostly look if you if you
were a successful business and you work
really really hard oh I get it but if
you're like a dude
who can't get an edit button done in a
year and a failing company that somehow
I just it's my it's mind-blowing to me
I'd rather the homeless guy had the
money at least he might do something
funny like make a pie machine or
something or I don't know buy himself an
infinity pool
all right so lay cucumber lime says okay
Tim fine I got you 2022 remake of the
old Brewster's Millions
what was that it was like a dollar bet
or something what was Brewster's
Millions
Brewster's Millions it's yeah sounds
familiar I don't remember what it is
though it was it was it a movie from
1985 American comedy film directed by
Walter Hill Stars Richard Pryor and John
Candy all right I'm sold what's it about
it was like they made a bet or something
Brewsters something about a baseball
minor league baseball player must spend
30 million dollars in 30 days in order
to inherit 300 million dollars yeah oh
wow he's not allowed to own any assets
destroy the money gift it give it away
the definition the description
Brewster's Millions what would you do
with it yeah so you could spend the
money by buying property like crazy but
then people understand you gotta you
gotta manage the property he's also not
allowed to tell anyone about the deal
so right
it's 30 million in 1985. yeah that's
even crazy and and so one thing you
could do is you could uh go if I mean if
you count on assets yeah no assets my
recommendation go to an ad agency and
say I've got a 30 million dollar budget
for the month and I want to spend it all
right now and they would say we got you
because if you're looking at putting up
Billboards in the entirety across the
country you retain nothing from that and
you can easily spend it all if you're
hitting every Major Market yep yeah the
movie would fail today because you just
put into Facebook ads or something
that's a good point put it on Twitter 30
million all anyone sees is your face
everywhere but the money's gone
yeah maybe they maybe they make you
spend it over time so you couldn't get
it all spent right away I don't know
they some they do they do put those
throttles on a lot of AD spending
particularly for political spending all
right last last Super Chat from Raymond
g Stanley Jr says holy moly those fart
sounds to that weirdo Super Chat that's
right if you haven't already would you
kindly smash hit that like button do it
now subscribe to the channel share the
show with your friends become a member
at timcast.com we have members only
exclusive episodes uncensored Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM you don't want
to miss it so uh turn the knob up and
rip it off
you can follow the show at Tim cast iron
you can follow me at timcast Gavin do
you want to shout anything out uh follow
me on Twitter at gavinwax and thank you
guys for having me everyone on uh in the
chats asking if you ask
but that's a separate topic all the time
I'm just messing with you my website's
lukeansensor.com I did a video there
titled the hack that many people don't
want to tell you about I get into the
weeds the nitty-gritty I've done a lot
of work with my own members area I put a
lot of Blood Sweat and Tears into it
check it out Lucan sensor.com see you
there I'm Ian Crossland you can follow
me at Ian crossland.net uh or just Eddie
and cross on across all social media
platforms thanks guys for tagging me and
things you like that you think I would
like because I've seen a lot of cool
interesting stuff recently and
especially this topical stuff with
Twitter getting bought and everything
looking forward to seeing you next week
have a fantastic weekend and I am
answers.com on Twitter now which is
great I'll see you guys around I'll be
in the comments too smash that like
button on your way out thanks for
hanging out we've got Clips going up on
this channel all weekend so don't miss
them and we will see you all next time
cheers